Hello, everyone, and welcome to your second drink of The Duel.
This might be one of my all-time favorite episodes of The Office.
I know I say that so often.
I also just really happen to like season five.
Yeah, it's really solid.
Well, there's just so many great moments in the Duel.
I love the Andy and Dwight Duel over Angela,
but there's also all the scenes with Michael and David Wallace in New York.
大家好，欢迎收听你们的第二杯《办公室风云》播客。这可能是我个人最喜欢的《办公室风云》剧集之一。我知道我经常这么说。但我确实非常喜欢第五季。是的，这一季真的很扎实。嗯，在《决斗》这一集中有太多精彩的瞬间了。我喜欢安迪和德怀特为了安吉拉而进行的决斗，但迈克尔和戴维·华莱士在纽约的所有场景也同样精彩。
I'm very curious to hear what the fan favorite moment of this episode was.
Well, we got this letter from Melissa Kay.
Melissa says, hi, ladies, absolutely love your show.
And one of my absolute favorite scenes from the whole show is at 10 minutes and 53 seconds
when Michael is talking about his philosophy to David Wallace and says,
don't ever for any reason do anything to anyone for any reason.
It goes on and on with this line.
I love this line so much, and it completely captures the moment.
我非常好奇粉丝们最喜欢这一集的哪个瞬间。嗯，我们收到了梅丽莎·凯的一封信。梅丽莎说，嗨，女士们，非常喜欢你们的节目。我整部剧中最喜欢的场景之一是在10分53秒，当时迈克尔正在向戴维·华莱士讲述他的哲学，他说，永远不要因为任何原因，对任何人做任何事，无论出于什么原因。他一直喋喋不休地说着这句台词。我太喜欢这句台词了，它完美地捕捉到了那一刻。
When you're asked a question, you don't know the answer to, and you have to make it up as you go.
Was all of that improvised or was it fully scripted?
Thanks, Melissa.
Okay, so Melissa, we talked about this in our breakdown, how Steve improvised a lot of this, but we didn't play it.
And I pulled a clip from the superfan version because there is an extra joke at the top and it really cracked us up.
Let's hear it.
My philosophy is basically this.
I like to sell paper for more than I bought the paper for.
当你被问到一个你不知道答案的问题，而你必须边想边编时。那段是即兴发挥的，还是完全照着剧本演的？谢谢你，梅丽莎。好的，梅丽莎，我们在解析中讨论过，史蒂夫即兴发挥了很多内容，但我们当时没放出来。我从超级粉丝版本中剪辑了一个片段，因为开头有一个额外的笑话，真的把我们逗乐了。让我们听听看。我的哲学基本上是这样的。我喜欢卖纸，卖出的价格比我买入的价格高。
That's obviously obvious.
But here's the thing, and this is something that I live by.
And I always have, and I always will.
Don't ever, for any reason, do anything to anyone,
for any reason, ever, no matter what, no matter what,
where or who or who you are with,
or where you are going,
or where you've been, ever,
这显然是显而易见的。但重点是，这是我赖以生存的信条。我一直以来都是这样，将来也永远会是这样。永远不要，因为任何原因，对任何人做任何事，因为任何原因，永远，无论发生什么，无论什么，在哪里，或者你是谁，或者你和谁在一起，或者你要去哪里，或者你去过哪里，永远，
for any reason whatsoever.
Sometimes I'll start a sentence,
and I don't even know where's going.
I just hope I find it along the way.
Like an improv conversation, an improvisation.
I mean, it's something he lives by and always will.
for any reason.
For any reason.
因为任何原因。有时我开始说一句话，甚至不知道它会通向哪里。我只是希望在过程中能找到答案。就像一场即兴对话，一种即兴创作。我是说，这是他赖以生存的信条，而且永远会是。因为任何原因。因为任何原因。
So not only was this our fan favorite moment of the episode,
we also got a letter that this scene is educational.
Listen to this.
Angela B. wrote in and said,
more of a comment for this episode,
I taught English 101 at a university
which focused on college writing.
Every semester, whenever I did a lesson on needing
所以这不仅是我们这一集中粉丝最喜欢的瞬间，我们还收到了一封信，说这个场景很有教育意义。听听这个。安吉拉·B写信说，对于这一集，我更多的是想发表一个评论，我曾在大学教过英语101，重点是大学写作。每个学期，每当我讲到需要
to have a purpose for writing,
I would show the clip from this episode
where Michael starts to answer David Wallace's question
and later says that he doesn't always know
where his sentences are going to go.
It's a great example about how,
if you don't know what the point of your argument or statement is,
you'll end up with meandering thoughts.
为写作设定一个目的时，我都会播放这一集的片段，迈克尔开始回答戴维·华莱士的问题，后来他说他并不总是知道他的句子会通向哪里。这是一个很好的例子，说明如果你不知道你的论点或陈述的重点是什么，你最终会陷入漫无边际的思考中。
That's so wonderful.
Hey, you know what?
Just get it down on paper.
You'll find it, right?
Well, Angela, you might remember
that I got really into the subject of dueling
when we did this episode.
Yes, I was.
那真是太棒了。嘿，你知道吗？只要把它写在纸上就行了。你会找到方向的，对吧？嗯，安吉拉，你可能还记得我们在做这一集时，我深入研究了决斗这个主题。是的，我研究过。
I did a little deep dive on the rules of dueling.
Well, we got some mail from folks that took my dive even deeper.
And I'm going to read two letters that really tickled me.
The first is from Laura H who said,
Hi, I really enjoyed the dual podcast episode.
To add to your discussion of dueling,
I wanted you to know that as an attorney in Kentucky,
I had to be sworn in by the state Supreme Court.
我稍微深入研究了一下决斗的规则。嗯，我们收到了一些粉丝的来信，他们让我的研究更深入了。我要读两封让我觉得很有趣的信。第一封来自劳拉·H，她说，嗨，我非常喜欢《决斗》那期播客。为了补充你们关于决斗的讨论，我想让你们知道，作为肯塔基州的一名律师，我必须由州最高法院进行宣誓就职。
As part of the swearing-in process,
attorneys have to solemnly swear, quote,
that since the adoption of the present Constitution,
I, being a citizen of this state,
have not fought a duel with deadly weapons within this state,
nor out of it, nor have I sent or accepted a challenge
to fight a duel with deadly weapons,
nor have I acted as a second in carrying a challenge,
作为宣誓过程的一部分，律师们必须庄严宣誓，引用如下：“自从现行宪法通过以来，我作为本州公民，未在本州内或州外进行过致命武器决斗，也未曾发出或接受过致命武器决斗的挑战，也未曾作为助手参与传递挑战，
nor aided or assisted any person thus offending.
My goodness.
Laura said the discussion regarding dueling is nearly half of the entire oath.
That's bonkers.
It was really funny to say that during the ceremony.
And then Nicole C wrote in to say,
I enjoyed hearing your history of dueling and wanted to let you know something else.
I am a lawyer in the military, a jag.
也没有协助或帮助过任何触犯此规定的人。”我的天哪。劳拉说，关于决斗的讨论几乎占了整个誓词的一半。这太疯狂了。在仪式上说这些话真的很滑稽。然后妮可·C写信说，我很喜欢听你们讲决斗的历史，想告诉你们另一件事。我是一名军方律师，也就是军法官。
And the military has its own set of rules called the Uniform Code of Military Justice or UCMJ.
There is an article in the UCMJ, Article 114, that makes it illegal for military members to duel,
to promote a duel, to not take action in stopping a duel, or to fail to report a duel.
So no dueling again.
But then Nicole goes on to say that when we prepare to court-martial someone, they have models of the argument that they make.
and Nicole said if we were going to court-martial Andy for dueling,
here is how that would be argued.
Quote, in that Andy Bernard did at or near the Scranton Business Park on or about this date,
军队有自己的一套规则，称为《统一军事司法法典》或UCMJ。UCMJ中有一条，第114条，规定军人进行决斗、煽动决斗、不采取行动阻止决斗或不报告决斗是违法的。所以，再次强调，禁止决斗。但妮可接着说，当我们准备对某人进行军事法庭审判时，他们有论证模型。妮可说，如果我们要在军事法庭上审判安迪决斗，论点会是这样的。引用如下：“安迪·伯纳德在或接近斯克兰顿商业园，在或大约在此日期，
fight a duel with Dwight Shrewt using as a weapon, therefore, a Toyota Prius.
But Nicole says there could also be a court-martial for Angela for promoting a duel,
and it would sound like this.
In that Angela Martin did at or near the Scranton Business Park
on or about this date promote a duel between Dwight Shrewd and Andy Bernard by telling Andy
he would be a coward if he failed to challenge Dwight to a duel.
So two sets of charges.
I guess though maybe Dwight should be charged as well.
与德怀特·舒鲁特进行了一场决斗，使用的武器是丰田普锐斯。”但妮可说，安吉拉也可能因为煽动决斗而受到军事法庭审判，听起来会是这样：“安吉拉·马丁在或接近斯克兰顿商业园，在或大约在此日期，通过告诉安迪如果他不挑战德怀特决斗就是个懦夫，从而煽动了德怀特·舒鲁特和安迪·伯纳德之间的决斗。”所以有两套指控。我想也许德怀特也应该被指控。
He did participate.
I found that all fascinating.
I mean, people had a lot of thoughts on dueling.
Dueling was like a big deal.
Big deal.
Well, listen, everyone, thank you for tuning in.
Thank you for writing in.
Please write us your fan favorite moments over in our second drinks folder at
他确实参与了。我觉得这一切都很迷人。我是说，人们对决斗有很多想法。决斗曾经是一件大事。大事。好了，听着，各位，感谢收听。感谢来信。请把你们粉丝最喜欢的瞬间写信发到我们的“第二杯”文件夹，地址是
OfficeLadies.com.
And now please enjoy the duel, but don't do a duel.
No.
And we've got really great tidbits in this one, too, from Jen Salata, Director Dean Holland
and producer Randy Cordray, so go give it a listen.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on the office together.
OfficeLadies.com。现在请享受《决斗》这一集，但不要真的去决斗。不。这一集里我们还有来自詹·萨拉塔、导演迪恩·霍兰德和制片人兰迪·科德雷的精彩花絮，所以去听听吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室风云》。
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast,
just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Lady, it's the
duel. I mean, two men are going to fight over me today. Me, aka Angela Martin. I have to say,
like Andy's Prius, this episode sneaked up on me, but in a great way, oh my gosh, hidden gem.
It's so good. It's one of my favorite episodes. I think.
I loved watching it. I loved filming it. And I'm excited to talk about it today.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室风云》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室风云》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。女士们，这是《决斗》。我是说，今天有两个男人要为我而战。我，也就是安吉拉·马丁。我必须说，就像安迪的普锐斯一样，这一集悄悄地吸引了我，但方式很棒，天哪，隐藏的宝石。太棒了。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我想是这样。我喜欢看它。我喜欢拍摄它。今天我很兴奋能谈论它。
Well, it is Season 5, Episode 12, written by Jen Salata and directed by Dean Holland. Here's your summary. Michael takes it upon himself to expose Angela and Dwight's affair to Andy. The two men then challenge one another to a duel in the parking lot. Meanwhile, Michael is summoned to corporate to speak with David Wallace. He thinks it's going to be bad news, but he gets some unexpected.
praise. Oh, those scenes. We'll get to it, but man, those are good, too. Fast fact number one,
this episode was written by the always amazing Jen Salada. Applaus for Jen. Oh, Jen.
Jen, so many good lines in this. I reached out to Jen, and she sent in an audio clip explaining
the inspiration behind this episode. Let's hear it. My biggest memory about writing the duel was how
little I had when I was sent off to write the script. It was mid-season five, and it was a really
busy patch for the writers, for all of us. And I remember this episode had to be written really, really
quickly. And I knew it was about Andy finding out about Angela and Dwight's affair. But where we'd
嗯，这是第五季第12集，由詹·萨拉塔编剧，迪恩·霍兰德执导。这是剧情摘要。迈克尔自作主张向安迪揭露了安吉拉和德怀特的恋情。这两个男人随后在停车场向对方发起了决斗挑战。与此同时，迈克尔被召集到公司与戴维·华莱士谈话。他以为会有坏消息，但他得到了一些意想不到的赞扬。哦，那些场景。我们稍后会讲到，但天哪，那些场景也很棒。快讯第一条，这一集是由一直很棒的詹·萨拉塔编写的。为詹鼓掌。哦，詹。詹，这一集里有太多好台词了。我联系了詹，她发来一段音频片段，解释了这一集的灵感来源。让我们听听。关于写《决斗》我最大的记忆是，当我被派去写剧本时，我手头的东西很少。那是第五季中期，对编剧们来说，对我们所有人来说，那是一段非常忙碌的时期。我记得这一集必须写得非常非常快。我知道内容是关于安迪发现了安吉拉和德怀特的恋情。但通常我们作为小组花时间梳理故事的地方，我却只带着一句话就开始写这个剧本了。安迪开着普锐斯撞向德怀特，速度保持在每小时五英里以下，这样德怀特就听不到他靠近。我是说，那是个好句子。但有很多内容需要填充。就是这样。她只有一个句子。而她创作了这个精彩的故事。是的。为什么安迪要用普锐斯慢慢地撞向德怀特？她不知道。
usually spend time as group flushing out the story, I went off on this script with a sentence.
Andy runs over Dwight and his Prius, keeping it under five miles an hour so Dwight doesn't hear
him coming. I mean, it was a good sentence. But there was a lot to fill in. That was it.
It. She had a sentence.
And she crafted this amazing story.
Yes.
Why Andy was going to run over Dwight slowly with a Prius?
She didn't know.
她只知道这一集里会发生这件事。这就是她想出来的。她必须为那一刻做铺垫。因为通常他们会得到完整的提纲。他们会有A线剧情，B线剧情，所有这些。没有。太神奇了。詹·萨拉塔。
She just knew that was going to happen in the episode.
And this is what she came up with.
She had to build to that moment.
Because usually they would get whole outlines.
They would have an A plot, a B plot, all of it.
No.
Amazing.
Jen Salada.
太神奇了。鼓掌，詹。太神奇了。快讯。第二条，这一集是由迪恩·霍兰德执导的。迪恩是我们除了戴夫·罗杰斯之外的另一位剪辑师。我们爱迪恩。我们爱迪恩，他非常了解这部剧，就像戴夫一样。
Amazing.
Appal applause, Jen.
Fast fact.
Number two, this episode was directed by Dean Holland.
Dean was our other editor alongside Dave Rogers.
We love Dean.
We love Dean, and he knew the show so well, much like Dave.
他们了解每一个瞬间。哦，是的。迪恩告诉我，他曾为MTV执导过一些东西，但这是他第一次执导电视剧集。他太紧张了，以至于在剧组集合时在洗手间吐了。噢。当他给我发短信说这件事时，我说，你在开玩笑吗？他说，不，我是认真的。
They knew every moment.
Oh, yeah.
Dean told me that he had directed something for MTV,
but that this was his first time directing an episode of television.
He was so nervous that he threw up in the bathroom at Crew Call.
Aw.
When he texted me that, I was like, are you joking?
He said, no, I'm being serious.
我在洗手间呕吐了。噢。他说这真的很令人生畏，因为他是从剪辑转过来的，没有在片场花太多时间。你知道，剪辑师的生活是非常孤立的。他们只是待在剪辑室里。虽然我们会过去打个招呼，但这和片场的工作方式非常不同。他说他感觉自己有点像异乡的陌生人。这是他的原话。
I vomited in the bathroom.
Aw.
He said that it was really daunting because he had come from editing and he hadn't spent a lot of time on set.
You know, editor's life is very isolating.
They're just in their editing room.
And while we would pop over and say hello, it's very different than how a set works.
And he said he felt a little bit like a stranger in a strange land.
Those were his words.
但他还说他咨询过保罗·费格，但最重要的是，他为这一集做了大量的准备工作。他说他对剧本了如指掌，听听这个。他说剧本从我们的剧本朗读会开始几乎没有变动。所以这很好，因为他一直在为那个朗读会草稿做准备。很多时候，你知道，在朗读会之后，他们会回来，整个场景都没了，还有新的情节。但没有。哦，是的。他说他很高兴没有太多改变。
But he also said he'd consulted a little bit with Paul Figue, but more than anything, he did a ton of prep work for this episode.
He said he knew the script inside and out, and listen to this.
He said it changed very little from our table read.
So that was good because he had been prepping and prepping on that table read draft.
And a lot of times, you know, after the table read, they'll come back and the whole scenes are gone and new plots.
But no.
Oh, yeah.
He said he was really happy that not a lot changed.
但我认为，再次强调，詹·萨拉塔。是的。显然从一开始就搞定了这一集。她搞定了。所以这是兰迪·科德雷告诉我的一个小秘密，安吉拉。你知道，他是我们的执行制片人，负责为导演安排时间表。是的，所以他一定知道迪恩什么时候执导。他操纵了时间表，让迪恩接手这一集，因为当他读到剧本时，他认为迪恩是执导这一集的完美人选。
But I think, again, Jen Salada.
Yeah.
Clearly nailed this one from the beginning.
She nailed it.
So here's a little secret that Randy Cordray told me, Angela.
You know, he's our line producer and he's in charge of setting the schedule for the directors.
Yeah, so he must have known when Dean was directing.
He manipulated the schedule so that Dean would get this episode because when he read it, he thought Dean would be perfect to direct it.
哦，天哪。兰迪，看看你。我知道。是的。他说他真的很想让迪恩执导这一集，作为他的导演处女作。我是说，真是份大礼。哇。嗯，这对整个三角恋，德怀特、安迪、安吉拉来说，确实是非常重要的一集。
Oh, my God.
Randy, look at you.
I know.
Yeah.
He said he really wanted Dean to get this one for his directorial debut.
I mean, what a gift.
Wow.
Well, this was a really big episode, you know, for the whole love triangle, the Dwight, Andy, Angela.
一切都到了紧要关头。其实，我对这一集感到很紧张。我只是知道我想把这些时刻演好。珍娜，这是一个棘手的场景，因为安吉拉既担心他们两个，又感到内疚，但同时，我不知道她是否被激起了兴趣。我不知道。发生了很多事。我知道迪恩这周在执导我，我感到非常安全，因为，我们了解他。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我可以走到他面前说，迪恩，我那样做对吗？你觉得呢？我应该尝试别的方法吗？所以我很高兴有迪恩在场执导《决斗》。嗯，不久之后，他去做了《公园与游憩》。
It was all coming to a head.
And I was nervous, actually, about this episode.
I just knew that I wanted to play these moments right.
And it was a tricky kind of scenario, Jenna, because it's like Angela is worried about both of them and feeling
guilt, but also, I don't know as she turned on. I don't know. It was a lot happening. And I felt very safe knowing
Dean was directing me this week because, like, we knew him. You know what I mean? Yes. And I could go up to him
and be like, Dean, did I do that right? What do you think? Should I try something else? So I felt very
happy to have Dean there for the duel. Well, shortly after this, he went over to do Parks and Rec.
他是那里的剪辑师。是的。他在那里执导了很多集。但是，多年后，我有机会和他重聚，因为他是ABC我的节目《分分合合》的执行制片人和导演。是的。然后我有机会去你的节目客串。我见到了迪恩和我们的音效部门。那就像一场小型的《办公室风云》重聚。我很喜欢那天。那是愉快的一天。是的。好了。快讯第三条。决斗的历史。什么？什么？哦，不。你的电脑搜索记录里有什么？哦，不。首先，我只想说我不是历史学家。我只是一个爱用谷歌的女士。你只是一个喜欢谷歌的可爱女士。没错。但我确实读了四到五篇看起来很权威的关于决斗主题的网站。这就是我
He was the editor over there. Yeah. He directed a bunch of episodes there. But,
But then years later, I got to be reunited with him because he was the executive producer and director of my show over at ABC splitting up together.
Yes. And then I got to come and do a guest spot on your show. And I got to see Dean and our sound department. It was like a mini office reunion.
I loved that day. It was a fun day. It was. All right. Fast fact number three. The history of dueling.
What? What? Oh, no. What is your search history?
on your computer. Oh, no. First of all, I would just like to say I am not a historian. I'm just a
lady with Google. You're just a delightful lady that loves to Google. That's right. But I did read
about four to five what seemed like reputable websites on the subject of dueling. And here is what I have
整理出来的。好的。决斗似乎起源于中世纪的欧洲。贵族们会在一对一的战斗中捍卫他们的荣誉。嗯，听着，如果你看过《古战场传奇》，你就知道那是真的。我没看过。来吧。来吧，萨萨纳克。来吧。嗯，1777年，一群爱尔兰人编纂了决斗惯例。
pulled together. Okay. Dueling seems to have originated in medieval Europe. Nobles would
defend their honor in man-to-man battles.
Well, listen, if you watch Outlander, you know that's true.
I don't.
Come on.
Come on, Sassanak.
Well, in 1777, a group of Irishmen codified the dueling practices.
他们写了一份规则文件，听听他们是怎么称呼它的。他们称之为“决斗法典”。决斗法典。我敢肯定那是一种你可以买到的甜点。我要一份决斗法典，谢谢。我喜欢柠檬味的。它包含了26条非常具体的规则，概述了决斗的各个方面，包括可以接受挑战的时间，以及获胜所需的射击或受伤次数。我觉得德怀特会知道这26条决斗规则，因为他有40条规则。所有舒鲁特男孩在五岁之前都必须学习。他喜欢规则。我觉得德怀特知道这些决斗规则。他一定知道。对吧？他建议决斗。哦，我肯定他知道。我肯定其中一些规则已经进入了舒鲁特的生活。进入了舒鲁特40条规则？是的。美国有记录的第一场决斗发生在1621年的马萨诸塞湾殖民地。好的。然后
They wrote a document of rules, and listen to what they called it.
They called it code duelo.
Code duelo.
I'm pretty sure that's a type of dessert you can get. I'll have the codewello, thanks. I love the lemon flavor. It consisted of 26 very specific rules outlining all aspects of the duel, including the time of day during which challenges could be received, the number of shots or wounds required in order to win. I feel like Dwight would have known these 26 rules of dueling because he had the 40 rules.
all shrewd boys have to learn before they're five. He loves rules. I feel like Dwight knows about these
dueling rules. He must. Right? He suggested the duel. Oh, I'm sure he knew. I'm sure that some of
these rules have made their way into the shrewd life. Into the shrewd 40 rules? Yes. The first
recorded duel in America took place in 1621 in the Massachusetts Bay Colony. Okay. And then
美国制定了他们自己的一套决斗规则。哦。它们是由南卡罗来纳州州长约翰·威尔逊在1838年编写的。所以在典型的美国决斗中，每一方都必须通过一名助手行事。大家都知道，我从音乐剧《汉密尔顿》里知道这一点。是的，是的，是的。哦，就像你有和你一起去的伙伴。是的，你有一个助手。
America created their own set of dueling rules.
Oh.
They were written by South Carolina Governor John Wilson in 1838.
So in a typical American duel, each party has to act through a second.
I know this from the musical Hamilton, everyone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, like you have your partner that goes with you.
Yes, you have a second.
没错。是的，是的，是的。而且你不能带个医护人员吗？比如医生？哦，那是《古战场传奇》。没关系。那不是。杰米，杰米会带萨萨纳克一起去。好的，没关系。继续。我不知道那个。好的。我只读了四到五篇网站。好的。如果我们有一位历史学家，也许他们会知道。
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And don't you get to bring like a medic?
Like a doctor? Oh, that's an outlander. Never mind.
That wasn't. Jamie, Jamie would bring Sassanac with him. Okay, never mind. Go.
I don't know about that. Okay.
I only read four to five websites.
Okay. If we have a historian, perhaps they would know.
你应该看《古战场传奇》，但不要在孩子在场时看。好的。所以听着，如果一个人觉得他的荣誉受到了侮辱，他会告诉他的助手去挑战冒犯者进行决斗。你不能自己做。你派人去。你派你的助手去。助手的主要职责是尝试达成和解，以避免暴力。哦，所以那个人就像调解员。是的，我是说，他们实际上是在做所有治疗师告诉我们不要做的事情，那就是三角化沟通，以便，你知道，解决冲突。但不管怎样，这是决斗。
You should watch Outlander, but don't watch it with your children around.
Okay. So listen, if a man felt like his honor had been insulted, he would tell his second to challenge the offender to a duel. You do not do it yourself. You send it.
You send your second.
The main duty of the second is to try to create a reconciliation, to avoid violence.
Oh, so that person's like the mediator.
Yeah, I mean, they're literally doing what all therapists tell us not to do, which is to triangulate
communication in order to, you know, solve conflicts.
But whatever, this is dueling.
我是我家里的助手。我经常是被派去平息其他事情的人。我想很多人在家里都有这个位置。我明白了。但如果助手去了说，嘿，我的人被你冒犯了，想决斗，而那个人说，好，我们决斗吧，决斗挑战的接受者可以选择决斗的武器、时间和地点。例如，詹姆斯·希尔兹和伊利诺伊州总检察长挑战了未来的总统，亚伯拉罕·林肯总统进行决斗。哦，天哪。
I'm the second in my family.
I'm often the person sent in to smooth over the other stuff.
I think a lot of people have that position in their family. I get it. But if the second goes and said,
hey, my guy is offended by you and wants to duel and the person says, great, we're dueling,
the recipient of the dual challenge gets to pick the weapons and the time and the place of the duel.
So, for example, James Shields and Illinois Attorney General challenged future presidents,
President Abraham Lincoln to a duel.
Oh my gosh.
林肯接受了决斗，他选择了阔剑作为他们的武器。詹姆斯·希尔兹当时就像，什么鬼？那太疯狂了。没关系。算了吧。他取消了决斗。所以，林肯真是大胆。林肯就像，我会出席，而且我会带着我的剑去决斗。
Lincoln accepted the duel and he chose the broadsword as their weapon.
James Shields was like, what the F?
That's insane.
Never mind.
Forget it.
And he called off the duel.
So like, bold move by Lincoln.
Lincoln's like, I'll show up and I'm bringing my sword to the duel.
你想要吗？林肯就像，我很高，而且我有一把剑。是的。詹姆斯·希尔兹就像，没关系。你知道吗？我很好。你知道吗？我想过了，我没事。这里有一个。这个真的让我很吃惊。我猜安德鲁·杰克逊非常出名，因为他喜欢决斗。哦。很多决斗，这家伙。专家估计他的决斗次数可能多达一百次。一百次。安德鲁是不是在惹恼所有人？他就是在惹恼所有人。每个人都想和他打架。他最著名的决斗是与查尔斯·迪金森，不要和作家查尔斯·狄更斯混淆。哦，我正想说，你看到我脸上的表情了吗？我当时想，等等，等等，什么？
Do you want it?
Lincoln was like, I'm tall and I'm a sword.
Yeah. James Shields was like, never mind. You know what? I'm good. You know what? I thought about it and I'm okay.
Here's one. This one really got me. I guess Andrew Jackson was very famous for dueling. Oh. Lots of
duels, this guy. Experts placed his number of duels maybe as many as a hundred. A hundred.
Was Andrew just pissing everyone off? He was just pissing everyone off. Everyone wanted to fight him.
His most famous duel was with Charles Dickinson, not to be confused with Charles Dickens, the writer.
Oh, I was going to say, did you see my look on my face? I was like, wait, wait, what?
是的，不，查尔斯·迪金森，他是个养马人，我猜这两个家伙互相憎恨。迪金森指控杰克逊在赛马赌博中作弊，并挑战杰克逊进行决斗。杰克逊就像，我会去的。武器是手枪。但重点是。迪金森被认为是全国最好的射手之一。所以我不知道为什么安德鲁·杰克逊选择了手枪，但他确实选了。我想也许那只是，我不知道，某种虚张声势之类的，对吧？所以他们出现了，他们决斗。是的。迪金森开了第一枪。它击中了安德鲁·杰克逊的胸部。他胸部在流血。好的。所有记录都说他一只手按住伤口，举起手枪，向迪金森开火。他的手枪走火了，没射出子弹。
Yeah, no, Charles Dickinson, he was a horse breeder, and I guess these two guys hated each other.
Dickinson accused Jackson of cheating on a horse bet, and he challenged Jackson to a duel.
Jackson was like, I'll be there. The weapon is pistols. But here's the thing. Dickinson was like known to be one of the best.
shots in the nation. So I don't know why Andrew Jackson picked pistols, but he did. I think maybe
it was just, I don't know, some swagger or something, right? So they show up, they duel.
Yeah. Dickinson got off the first shot. It hit Andrew Jackson in the chest. He's bleeding from the chest.
Okay. All accounts are that he like held one hand to the wound, lifted his pistol, fired at Dickinson.
his pistol misfired, it didn't shoot.
哦。所以安德鲁·杰克逊重新扣动了手枪，再次开火，杀死了迪金森。这非常有争议，安吉拉。在决斗规则中，你只能开火一次。那正是我要说的。不是一枪定胜负吗？我对决斗一无所知，但我很确定是这样。谢谢你，《汉密尔顿》。
Oh.
So Andrew Jackson recoct his pistol, fired again, and killed Dickinson.
This was very controversial, Angela.
In the rules of dueling, you only get to fire once.
That's what I was going to say.
Aren't you one and done?
And I know nothing about dueling, but I was pretty sure that's the case.
Thank you, Hamilton.
没错。是的。我不知道。安德鲁·杰克逊活了下来。他逃脱了惩罚，后来还当选为美国总统。我有一个问题。是什么？
That's right.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Andrew Jackson lived.
He got away with it and was later,
elected president of the United States.
I have a question.
What is it?
如果你是查尔斯·迪金森，你看到安德鲁·杰克逊用枪指着你要开火，你会跑Z字形吗？你可以闪开吗，还是你只能站在那里？祈祷它不会击中你。没有允许移动吗？我不能跳来跳去吗？我不知道。我不知道。因为我不会站在一个地方。
If you're Charles Dickinson, you see Andrew Jackson pointing his gun at you to fire, do you run a zigzag?
Can you step out of the way or do you just have to stand there?
Fingers crossed, it doesn't hit you.
Is there no movement allowed?
Can I not jump around?
I don't know.
Because I'm not going to stand in one place.
如果你用手枪指着我，我会开始移动。是的，我想你不被允许，安。哦。美国最后一次有记录的决斗是在1859年。好的。涉及的人是谁？是不是又是白人男人互相射击？确实是，女士。
If you're pointing a pistol at me, I'm going to get moving.
Yeah, I think you're not allowed, Ang.
Oh.
The last duel of record in the United States was in 1859.
Okay.
Here's who it involved.
Was it more white men shooting at each other?
It sure was, lady.
不仅如此，那是一位美国参议员和加州最高法院的一位退休首席大法官。哦。干得好，伙计们。没有人死在这场决斗中，因为，听听这个疯狂的事情。一个人的枪卡壳了。好的。然后另一个人开了枪，但它击中了另一个人的金怀表，他们达成了停战协议。就是这样。
Not only that, it was a United States senator and a retired chief justice of the California Supreme Court.
Oh.
Way to go, guys.
No one died in this duel because, listen to this madness.
one guy's gun jammed.
Okay.
And then the other guy fired his gun, but it hit the other guy in his gold pocket watch, and they called a truce.
There you go.
那是美国最后一次决斗。好了。现在，如果安德鲁·杰克逊在那里，他会把枪卡壳修好，然后再次向你开火。对吧？是的。我想说，我不知道安德鲁·杰克逊的助手是谁，但我认为他们做得真的很烂。迪金森的助手呢？迪金森的助手试图提出一个理由，你知道，安德鲁·杰克逊，我认为应该以谋杀罪审判，但没人想听。
That was the last duel in America.
All right.
Now, if Andrew Jackson was there, he would have unjammed his gun and shot at you again.
Right.
Yeah.
I would like to say, I don't know who Andrew Jackson's second was, but I think they did a real shitty job.
What about Dickinson's second?
Dickinson's second tried to make a case that, you know, Andrew Jackson, I think should be tried for murder, but no one wanted to hear about it.
那非常有趣。我喜欢你所有的决斗琐事。谢谢。我喜欢研究我的决斗琐事。我是说，我内心深处有一部分想和你一起做一个历史播客，但我们每件事都稍微搞错一点。嗯，我们已经在做了。我敢肯定我在这个快讯第三条里至少做错了12件事。你知道吗？这就像我们版本的“醉酒历史”，但我们没喝醉。是的。我们只是好心的女士，谷歌一下，然后告诉你们历史。好了。我们要休息一下吗？我想我们应该休息一下。关于这一集有很多话要说，我等不及了。
That was very interesting. I liked all your dual trivia.
Thank you. I enjoyed researching my dual trivia.
I mean, there is just a part of me that would do a history podcast with you, but we get everything slightly wrong.
Well, we're already doing that. I'm sure there are at least 12 things I did wrong in this fast fact number three.
You know what? It's like our version of drunk history, but we're not drunk.
Yes. We're just well-meaning ladies who Google and tell you history.
All right. Should we take a break?
I think we should. There's a lot to say about this episode, and I can't wait.
好的。第二次世界大战是人类历史上最大的事件。一个由汤姆·汉克斯主持的20集系列节目。全球没有一个地方未受影响。没有一个生命未被改变。体验关于第二次世界大战的终极叙述。每个人都有一个故事。这些故事造就了今天的我们。在Apple、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方收听汤姆·汉克斯的《第二次世界大战》。
All right.
The Second World War is the largest event in human history.
A 20-part series with Tom Hanks. No part of the globe was untouched.
No life unchanged.
Experience the ultimate account of World War II.
Every single person had a story.
These are the stories that make us who we are.
Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这一集以一个精彩的冷开场开始。拍摄起来太有趣了。是的。我喜欢再次观看它。我也是。电话响了。帕姆接了电话。有人找迈克尔，但迈克尔不在。迈克尔在哪里？哦，迈克尔在街上。他在跑。他在尖叫。有一个测速雷达标志。他不断地跑过它，试图看看他能跑多快。这就是迈克尔今天早上在做的事。这就是迈克尔在做的事。我们都在想为什么。嗯，帕姆分享说，安吉拉显然已经多次拨打911举报路上的汽车开得太快。所以警察过来安装了那种雷达屏幕，对吧，告诉你你的速度。是的。嗯，我猜，虽然，这在拍摄时非常困难
This episode opens with an amazing cold open.
It was so much fun to shoot.
Yeah.
I loved watching it again.
Me too.
The phone rings. Pam answers the phone. Someone for Michael, but Michael's not there. Where is Michael? Oh, Michael is down on the street. He's running. He's screaming. There is a speed radar sign. And he keeps running past it, trying to see how fast he can go. That's what Michael's doing this morning. That's what Michael's doing. And we're all wondering why. Well, Pam shares that Angela has apparently called 911 several times to report cars.
is going too fast outside on the road. And so the police came and put up this sort of like that radar
screen, right, that tells you your speed. Yes. Well, I guess, though, this was a really hard
场景。真的吗？是的。迪恩告诉我，我们必须在两个不同的地方拍摄。所以你在窗外看到的迈克尔跑步的任何画面，我们都必须从保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室拍摄。哦，好的。因为那是看向外面我们的停车场和街道的窗户。但当然，所有其他在室内的东西，我们必须在邓德·米夫林内部拍摄。顺便说一句，这稍后还会出现。是的。所以迪恩告诉我，对于那个开场时刻，帕姆在打电话，然后摄像机拉回到迈克尔空荡荡的办公室，然后它扫向窗户，你看到迈克尔在跑。是的。他必须使用那些鞭切镜头。所以他拍摄了帕姆，拉回到迈克尔的办公室，然后他扫向一个窗户，后面只是有一个
scene to shoot. Really? Yeah. Dean told me that we had to shoot this in two different places.
So anything that you see out the window of Michael running, we had to shoot that from Paul Lieberstein's
office. Oh, okay. Because that was the window that looked outside onto our parking lot and onto our
street. But of course, everything else that was indoors, we had to shoot inside Dunder Mifflin.
And by the way, this is going to come up again later. Yeah. So Dean told me that for that opening
moment where Pam is on the phone and then the camera pulls back into Michael's empty office and then
it whips over to the window and you see Michael running. Yeah. He had to use one of those whip cuts. So
he shot Pam, pull back into Michael's office, and then he whipped to a window that just had like a
幕布，对吧？因为迈克尔的办公室真的只有那个。是的，是的，在我们的片场，他的窗户后面什么都没有。是的。然后他走到保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室。他做了另一次扫动，然后让史蒂夫在外面跑过，他做了那种他在扫动中剪辑并把它拼在一起的事情。那是电影魔法，伙计们。电影魔法。现在我猜每个人都决定他们想知道他们能跑多快。感觉迈克尔强迫我们所有人出去跑过那个标志。德怀特非常热情。他很高兴跑过它。
scrim behind it, right? Because that's what Michael's office really has. Yeah, yeah, on our set,
there's nothing behind his window. Yeah. Then he went up to Paul Lieberstein's office. He did
another whip and then had Steve run by outside and he did that thing where he cut in the whip and put
it together. That's movie magic, guys. Movie magic. Now I guess everyone has decided
They want to know how fast they can run.
It feels like Michael has forced us all outside to run past the sign.
Dwight is very enthusiastic.
He's happy to run past it.
他跑过去，速度达到了每小时13英里。是的。嗯，珍娜，你注意到我们所有人只是，我们太冷了，我们在发抖吗？但实际上男人们汗流浃背。哦，是的。我去查了，因为我只是一个喜欢知道天气情况的老太太。我显然变成了我的父母，因为在我父母家，电视总是开着的，而且总是开在天气频道。
He runs past and he gets a speed of 13 miles per hour.
Yes.
Well, Jenna, do you notice how we're all just like, we're so cold and we're like,
shivering?
But truly the guys are like sweating their butts off.
Oh, yeah.
I went to, because I'm just an old lady who loves to know what the weather was.
I've clearly become my parents because at my parents' house, the TV is always on and it's always on the weather channel.
如果你需要知道任何地方的天气，只要给我妈妈打电话。她会告诉你的。所以我深入研究了我的数字杂物，发现我们是在2008年10月13日那一周拍摄这一集的。那一周的平均气温在90多度。兰迪告诉我，是的，那天不仅超过了90度，而且我们必须安排这个场景在午餐后拍摄。哦，恶心。所以我们都有饱腹感，太阳直接照在我们身上。是的。但他表示，幸运的是，拍摄只花了几个小时。几个小时。我知道。我们很幸运。哦，天哪，我总是感到难过。这是我为男人们感到难过的时刻，因为我们在舞台上冻得发抖。女士们是这样。我们总是穿得比较少。但当我们在这些停车场场景中，他们穿着全套西装，汗流浃背。
If you need to know what the weather is anywhere, just call my mom. She'll tell you.
So I dug into my digital clutter and found out we shot this episode the week of October 13th in 2008.
And the average temperature was in the 90s for this week.
Randy told me that, yeah, not only was it over 90 degrees that day, but we had to schedule this scene to shoot
right after lunch. Oh, gross. So we all had these full bellies and the sun was right directly over us.
Yeah. But he said, luckily, it only took a couple of hours to shoot. A couple of hours.
I know. Lucky for us. Oh, my, I always felt bad. This is the one moment I felt bad for the guys because we froze our butts off on the stage. The ladies did. We were always in less clothing. But then when we were in these parking lot scenes and they're in full suit,
and they are sweating their butts off.
而且带着饱腹感在跑。呃。我不得不想象我们在那个90度的停车场里相当舒服。我可能还好。我们很棒。所以天气很热，他们跑过那个雷达枪。你知道，德怀特得了13分，迈克尔想打破它。于是他又开始跑，一辆车经过，突然迈克尔测出了31分。
And running with full stomachs of food.
Ugh.
I have to imagine we were pretty comfortable out there in that 90-degree parking lot.
I was probably fine.
We were great.
So it is hot and they're running past this radar gun.
You know, Dwight scored a 13 and Michael wants to beat it.
And so he starts running again and a car goes by and all of a sudden Michael clock's 31.
他就像，耶。每个人都觉得那是胡扯。是的。嗯，我们收到了很多关于我们是如何在技术上实现这一点的疑问，对吧，关于这些速度数字。兰迪和我们分享说，机器就是那样工作的。它实际上是在测量人们真实的跑步速度和真实的汽车速度。但随后他与我们分享说，我们做这个冷开场的原因是受到我们编剧之一的真实生活经历的启发。是的。亚伦·舒尔，伙计们。
And he's like, yes.
And everyone kind of calls BS on that.
Yes.
Well, we got a lot of questions about how did we technically pull this off, right, with these speed numbers.
Randy shared with us that the machine just worked.
It was actually clocking people's real running speeds and the real car speed.
But then he shared with us the reason we did this cold open was inspired by one of our writers, real life experience.
Yes. Aaron Sure, you guys.
亚伦·舒尔总是能想出这些很棒的冷开场。我和他谈过。他对我来说太搞笑了，珍娜，因为他说，我想我的真实生活足够奇怪，以至于它能转化为一个很棒的冷开场。在为《办公室风云》工作之前，亚伦曾在《老克里斯汀的新冒险》工作。那是CBS的一个节目。是的，和朱莉娅·路易斯-德莱弗斯一起。没错。他们在华纳兄弟片场拍摄，他说在华纳兄弟片场，有这个雷达枪。他正和一些其他编剧从午餐食堂走回来。当他走过雷达枪时，它显示为零。
Aaron Sure is like always coming up with these great cold opens.
And I talked with him. He is so hilarious to me, Jenna, because he's like, I guess my real life is just weird enough that it translates into a great cold open.
Prior to working on the office, Aaron had been working on the new adventures of old Christine.
It was a show on CBS.
Yeah, with Julia Louis Dreyfus.
Exactly. They filmed on the Warner Brothers lot, and he said on the Warner Brothers lot, there was this radar gun.
And he was walking back from lunch from the conference.
commissary with some of the other riders. And as he walked past the radar gun, it said zero.
所以他就像，哦，是吗？所以他放下午餐，退后，他尽可能快地跑过它。令人惊讶的是，它测出了每小时20英里。那是他的记忆。不。那是他的记忆。他说其他编剧就像，等等，我想试试这个。他们退后，也开始跑过它。他说那天下午编剧室里汗流浃背。这太不可思议了。所以当他来到《办公室风云》时，他讲了这个故事，他们就像，哦，天哪，这正是德怀特和迈克尔会做的事。肯定的。在我们拍完这个之后，他们把那个速度计移到了餐饮区附近的停车场。
So he was like, oh, yeah? So he set his lunch down, backed up, and he ran as fast as he could by it.
Surprisingly, it clocked 20 miles per hour. That's his memory. No. That is his memory. He said other
writers were like, wait, I want to try this. They backed up and they started running past it as well.
And he said it was a very sweaty writer's room that afternoon.
That is incredible.
So he told this story when he came to the office and they were like, oh my gosh, like, this is something Dwight and Michael would do.
For sure.
After we were done filming this, they moved that speed meter onto the parking lot near catering.
它在那里放了整个制作周。嗯，我猜它太诱人了，无法忽视。哦，不。兰迪说有一天午餐时，一群编剧下去，他们开始冲刺跑过它。我们又来了。但随后，我猜发生了一起事故，女士。什么？记得我们的编剧瑞安·科吗？
And it sat there for the whole week of production.
Well, I guess it was too tempting to ignore.
Oh, no.
Randy said that one day during lunch, a bunch of the writers went down and they started sprinting past it.
Here we go again.
But then, I guess there was an accident, lady.
What?
Remember our writer Ryan Coe?
是的。我不记得有什么事故。是的。兰迪分享说，瑞安跑过速度计，结果不太好。哦，不。所以我联系了瑞安来了解这个故事。而且，女士，我没有告诉你这个，因为我觉得你需要直接从他那里听到。哦，上帝。
Yeah.
I don't remember an accident.
Randy shared that Ryan ran past the speed meter and it didn't go well.
Oh, no.
So I reached out to Ryan to get the story.
And, lady, I did not tell you this because I think you need to hear it from him directly.
Oh, God.
当他给我发邮件时，我大喊了一声，哦，不。当我读他的邮件时。他正在打电话，女士，来告诉我们这个故事。哦，天哪。瑞安。好了，他来了。所以，瑞安，你是第五季编剧组的一员。你写了《商业道德》，你写了《激烈的竞争》，但你打电话的原因是因为你有一个故事要讲。
When he emailed me, I literally shouted, oh, no.
As I was reading his email.
He's calling in, lady, to tell us this story.
Oh, my gosh.
Ryan.
All right, here he is.
So, Ryan, you were a member of the writing staff in season five.
you wrote business ethics, you wrote heavy competition, but the reason you're calling is because you have a story to tell.
是的，我想是这样。所以这一集的冷开场是迈克尔和德怀特跑出你的速度，就像那些让你在街道上减速的标志之一。是的。对吧，对吧。我们和亚伦·舒尔谈过这个。所以我们记得很清楚。我们不知道你也是速度竞赛的一部分。哦，是的。所以我应该说，兰迪·科德雷说，在我们拍完这个
Yeah, I guess so.
So the cold open of this episode is Michael and Dwight running out of your speed is like one of those signs that gets you to slow down on streets.
Yes.
Right, right.
We had spoke to Aaron Scher about this.
So we remember it well.
And we did not know you were also part of the.
speed racing. Oh, yeah. So I should say, Randy Cordray said that after we finished shooting this
场景后，他把速度追踪器放在停车场，一群人，编剧和剧组人员，都决定下去做这件事，跑过它。你是那些想跑过它的人之一。绝对。是的，我在第四季是编剧助理，在第五季仍然觉得在那里不安全。这是我向大家证明我至少是最快的一次机会。你是最快的编剧。这是你的时刻。是的。
scene, he put the speed tracker in the parking lot and a bunch of people, writers and crew,
all decided to go down and do this thing where you run past it. And you were one of the people
who wanted to run past it. Absolutely. Yeah, I was like a staff writer in season four and still
like felt insecure about being there in season five. And this is my
chance to prove everyone that I was at least the fastest.
You were the fastest writer.
This was your moment.
Yes.
但你在高中参加过田径比赛，对吧？我在我们非常小的学校部门的100米比赛中是新英格兰地区的第六名。哦，天哪，瑞安。全新英格兰地区的第六名？在非常小的学校里。但是的。所以我当时想，我要打败愚蠢的，那些愚蠢的老编剧。所以告诉我们发生了什么。
But you ran track in high school, right?
I was sixth in New England in the 100 in sort of our very small school division.
Oh my God, Ryan.
Sixth in all of New England?
In the very small schools.
But yes.
So I was like, I'm going to beat stupid, the stupid old writers.
So tell us what happened.
我今天早上重温了冷开场。所以史蒂夫和雷恩都跑了每小时12和13英里。是的，是的。然后几个编剧跑了，他们都跑了每小时12英里。然后我当时想，哦，我可以打败那个。所以我穿着灯芯绒裤子和查克·泰勒鞋。你只是穿着工作服。你没有像要跑步那样打扮。
I rewatched the cold open this morning.
And so like both Steve and Rain ran like 12 and 13 miles an hour.
Yeah, yeah.
And then a couple writers ran and they all got like 12 miles an hour.
And then I was like, oh, I can beat that.
So I had on corduroys and like Chuck Taylor's.
You were just in your work clothes.
You weren't like dressed to run.
你只是穿着那天上班穿的衣服。嗯，兰迪刚探出头说，谁想跑过速度计？我就说，好。所以是的，我真的系紧了鞋带。我是说，它们是那种宽松的查克鞋，还有那种一脚蹬的鞋。不管怎样，我把它们系得很紧。然后我开始跑。
You were just in what you wore to work that day.
Well, Randy just poked his head up and said like, who wants to?
to run at a speedometer.
And I was like, yeah.
So yeah, I like really laced up.
I mean, they're sort of loose-fitting chucks and there's sort of like a slip-on shoe.
Anyway, I lace them up really tight.
And then I started running.
我有这种记忆，就像昨天一样，我不知道你是否有过这种经历，当你跑得很快，然后你的脚下没有地面，你只是在风车般地摆动你的脚，下面没有地面。然后我非常清楚地记得看到，嗯，不清楚，因为我不记得确切了。但它大约是每小时17或18英里，然后我像飞到了空中，参考一下，这就像被从高尔夫球车里扔出来一样。嗯哼。还不算太糟。然后我的灯芯绒裤子完全撕碎了，从我的腿上撕下来。
And I have this memory like it was yesterday of, I don't know if you ever had this
experience where you're running fast and then there's no ground beneath your feet and
you're just sort of windmilling your feet with no ground underneath it.
And then I very clearly remember seeing, well, not clearly, because I don't remember exactly.
But it was like 17 or 18 miles an hour before I like sort of flew into the air, which for reference is like getting thrown out of a golf cart.
Uh-huh.
It's not too bad.
And then so like my my quarter eyes totally shredded, shredded off my legs.
所以我落在我的手肘和前臂上。丹·戈尔，他是观看的人之一，说你可以看出我真的受伤了，因为我立刻从地上弹起来说，我没事，我没事。这是人们在真正受伤时会做的事。但你伤得很重。医护人员确实不得不过来，对吧？我确实被木乃伊化了。我不得不在一个小时后去参加我表弟的婚礼。哦，不。他们用了，你知道，那种纱布，甚至不是绷带，而是，你知道，你可以看穿的那种纱布。他们把它缠在我的手臂和腿上，那些地方被擦破了。然后我上了飞机。
So I landed on my elbows and forearms.
And Dan Gore, who was one of the people watching.
said you could tell I was really hurt because I immediately popped off the ground and said like,
I'm fine, I'm fine. This is what people do when they're really hurt.
But you were pretty hurt. Like the medic did have to come over, right?
I did get really mummified. I had to go to my cousin's wedding like an hour afterwards.
Oh, no. They used, you know, like that gauze, not even like bandage, but, you know, that gauze that you can see through.
And they wrapped it all around my arms and legs, which were pretty skinned. And then I got on the plane.
所以我用手肘和前臂着地。当时在场观看的丹·戈尔说，他一眼就能看出我伤得很重，因为我立刻从地上弹起来说，我没事，我没事。这就是人们受重伤时的反应。但你确实伤得不轻。医护人员确实得过来处理，对吧？我确实被包得像个木乃伊一样。一小时后我还得去参加我表亲的婚礼。噢，不。他们用了那种纱布，甚至算不上绷带，就是那种半透明的纱布。他们把我擦伤严重的胳膊和腿全都缠了起来。然后我就上了飞机。
And then when I arrived in Portland, I went into the drugstore and bought a ton of nonstick gauze and stuff.
And then I had seen that all the scabs had formed like in the bandage.
Anyway, that's gross.
So I stood in the shower for like an hour, just unwrapping my mummified arms and sort of yelling in pain.
Oh, my God.
Right after I fell, I remember Randy immediately was like, all right, let's put this away.
No one else, no one else.
You know, they didn't want another idiot filing a lawsuit against the office.
然后当我到达波特兰时，我走进药店，买了一大堆不粘纱布之类的东西。然后我发现所有的痂都结在绷带里了。总之，那太恶心了。所以我站在淋浴下大概一个小时，一边拆掉我那木乃伊般的双臂，一边因为疼痛而大叫。天哪。我记得在我摔倒后，兰迪立刻说，好了，把这个收起来。别让其他人，别让其他人看到。你知道，他们不想再有一个白痴对办公室提起诉讼。
That was it.
I hurt myself.
I still have scars on all four of my limbs.
Oh, my gosh.
Sort of a decent story.
But you won.
You won.
You got the fastest speed.
就是这样。我伤到了自己。我的四肢上现在还有伤疤。天哪。算是一个还不错的故事。但你赢了。你赢了。你获得了最快速度。
So there's that.
I don't think anyone would call me the winner.
But sure, I do believe sort of I will definitely vouch for the fact that I got the fastest speed.
I mean, I help by disqualifying everyone by getting it removed.
Maybe that was my strategy.
get a high speed and then mangle myself so they get rid of the spedometer.
Ryan, thank you for coming on office ladies and telling your story.
We're going to hit you up for some trivia about heavy competition when we get to it if you don't mind.
所以就是这样。我不认为有人会称我为赢家。但当然，我确实相信，我绝对可以证明我获得了最快速度。我的意思是，我通过让每个人被取消资格来提供帮助，因为我把它拆除了。也许这就是我的策略。获得一个高速度，然后把自己弄得伤痕累累，这样他们就会把速度计拿走。瑞安，谢谢你来到《办公室女士》讲述你的故事。如果我们聊到重度竞争的话题，如果不介意的话，我们会向你请教一些琐事。
Okay, sounds great.
All right.
Love you, Ryan.
Talking to you.
Take care.
Bye.
Oh, my gosh.
好的，听起来不错。好的。爱你，瑞安。和你聊天很开心。保重。再见。再见。天哪。
This is like it's art imitating life.
Life imitating art.
written art back to life? Is that it? This is crazy. Do you remember early in the podcast when you said
life intimidating art? I do, Jenna. I do. It feels like life said to Ryan Coe, I'm going to intimidate you
by throwing you to the asphalt. Life is intimidating art. I think so. Life threw Ryan to the asphalt
in a very intimidating way based on his art. Oh man. Well, that is the cold open, you guys,
and we haven't even gotten to the episode yet. Let's get into it.
it because this is a big day. It's a big day for Michael because David Wallace wants to meet him
这就像是艺术模仿生活。生活模仿艺术。把艺术写回生活中？是这样吗？这太疯狂了。你还记得在播客早期你说过“生活恐吓艺术”吗？我记得，珍娜。我记得。感觉就像生活对瑞安·科说，我要通过把你扔到柏油路上来恐吓你。生活在恐吓艺术。我想是这样。生活以一种非常恐吓的方式把瑞安扔到了柏油路上，基于他的艺术。天哪。好吧，这就是冷开场，伙计们，我们甚至还没进入正题呢。让我们开始吧，因为今天是个大日子。这对迈克尔来说是个大日子，因为大卫·华莱士想见他
and talk to him about big picture stuff. Michael doesn't really know what that means. It's probably
bad. It's also a big day because Pam makes an announcement. New Year, new candy, hot tamales.
But did you notice at one minute, 50 seconds, that Pam has dark nail polish? I did not.
Oh, yeah. I took a picture to show you. And then I did a weird mini dive. All right, I want you to see. I'll put this in stories, but you got to see. Look at your nails.
How did I get away with that? Why did they let me do that?
I don't know. Because I will just say that if I ever came in with a nail polish that wasn't a natural looking nail polish, they would make me take it off in the trailer in the morning.
I don't know how this fell through the cracks, but I remember this nail polish on you.
Is this so weird?
并和他谈谈大局方面的事情。迈克尔并不真正知道那意味着什么。这可能不是什么好事。这也是个大日子，因为帕姆宣布了一个消息。新年，新糖果，热塔马利。但你有没有注意到在1分50秒时，帕姆涂了深色的指甲油？我没注意到。哦，是的。我拍了张照片给你看。然后我做了一个奇怪的小潜水。好吧，我想让你看看。我会把它发到故事里，但你必须看看。看看你的指甲。我是怎么蒙混过关的？他们为什么要让我那样做？我不知道。因为我只想说，如果我曾经涂着看起来不自然的指甲油进来，他们会让我早上在拖车里把它卸掉。我不知道这是怎么漏网的，但我记得你涂了这个指甲油。这不是很奇怪吗？
What is it?
I looked up on the Internet, and it said in the fall of 2008, one of the big trends in nail polish was gray nail polish.
In fact, collegecandy.com said the OPI Sephora had a very popular color called Metro Sheik, which was a matte purplish gray.
Well, I think we all know. If anything, I'm on trend. Hey, you know the fashions. I do. I really do.
I think you got some Metro chic and put it on your nails for the weekend.
I have no doubt. I love OPI nail polish. I wear it all the time. I am certain that's what it was.
I just can't believe I got away with it. You know, they would let Amy Ryan and Melora Hardin as their characters. They could have a darker nail polish.
But they wanted Pam to always, like, either have no nail polish or just some clear nail polish.
那是什么？我在网上查了一下，上面说在2008年秋天，指甲油的一大流行趋势是灰色指甲油。事实上，collegecandy.com说OPI Sephora有一款非常受欢迎的颜色叫“Metro Sheik”，那是一种哑光的紫灰色。好吧，我想我们都知道。如果说有什么的话，我是在追赶潮流。嘿，你知道时尚。我确实知道。我真的知道。我想你买了一些“Metro Sheik”并在周末涂在了指甲上。我毫不怀疑。我喜欢OPI指甲油。我一直都在用。我肯定那就是它。我只是不敢相信我竟然蒙混过关了。你知道，他们会让艾米·瑞安和梅洛拉·哈丁作为她们的角色。她们可以涂深色的指甲油。但他们希望帕姆总是要么不涂指甲油，要么只涂透明指甲油。
I sneaked it in, I guess.
Maybe I sat on my hands while I got my hair and makeup done that day.
Well, listen, Andy's going to come in and he's clearly upset about something.
He would like to address the elephant in the room.
I love how Rain Wilson, as Dwight, chose to kind of stand up and get in a power stance.
He's ready to fight because, of course, we all think that he's.
He knows about this affair that Angela is having with Dwight.
But that's not what he says.
我想我是偷偷涂的。也许那天我做头发和化妆的时候一直坐在手上。好吧，听着，安迪要进来了，他显然对某事感到不安。他想解决房间里的大象。我喜欢雷恩·威尔森饰演的德怀特选择站起来并摆出强硬姿态的方式。他准备好战斗了，因为当然，我们都认为他知道安吉拉和德怀特之间的这段婚外情。但那不是他说的。
He says, none of you have RSVP to our wedding.
How awkward.
In the deleted scenes, this scene goes on where he goes to every single person and is like, hey, Phyllis, you haven't RSVPed, Jim.
And everyone, like, pretends to be on the phone.
Oh, no.
You have this hilarious talking head where you're, like, you say you've been avoiding him and you can't look him in the eye so you only look at his nose.
And so then Andy comes up to you and asks you, and you're just awkwardly looking at his nose,
and then he thinks he has something on his nose.
他说，你们谁都没有回复我们的婚礼邀请。多尴尬啊。在删除的场景中，这个场景继续进行，他走到每个人面前说，嘿，菲利斯，你还没回复，吉姆。每个人都假装在打电话。哦，不。你有一个搞笑的谈话头，你说你在躲着他，你不敢看他的眼睛，所以你只看他的鼻子。然后安迪走过来问你，你只是尴尬地看着他的鼻子，然后他以为他的鼻子上有什么东西。
It was really funny.
The deleted scenes for this episode, I feel like every single one of them should have been in because they were all awesome.
Jim says it's been 17 days.
It's been 17 days since the Christmas party when Phyllis spilled the beans.
Everyone meets in the break room, except Andy, and Michael says he's going to tell him.
He has to tell him.
And of course, everyone's like, you can't.
It's really Angela's responsibility.
这真的很有趣。我觉得这一集的删除场景，每一个都应该保留，因为它们都很棒。吉姆说已经17天了。自从圣诞派对菲利斯说漏嘴以来已经17天了。除了安迪，每个人都在休息室见面，迈克尔说他要告诉他。他必须告诉他。当然，每个人都说，你不能。这实际上是安吉拉的责任。
Oh.
And then I loved the exchange between Oscar and Dwight.
Oh, I know.
I was anticipating it as you were about to say it.
And just the fact that the whole group starts learning where all Angela and Dwight have shagged in the office.
We had a fan question from Jess R who said, who wrote the most.
moment in the break room when Dwight implies he's been doing it with Angela on Oscar's desk and
was any of that scene improvised? No, none of it was improvised. It was all scripted by Jen Salada.
哦。然后我喜欢奥斯卡和德怀特之间的交流。哦，我知道。在你正要说出来的时候，我就预料到了。整个团队开始了解安吉拉和德怀特在办公室里所有发生过关系的地方，这事实本身就很有趣。我们有一个来自杰斯·R的粉丝提问，他说，谁在休息室里写了那个最尴尬的时刻，当时德怀特暗示他一直在奥斯卡的桌子上和安吉拉做那事，那个场景有即兴发挥吗？不，没有一个是即兴发挥的。全是珍·萨拉达写的剧本。
So good. This scene takes us into accounting and Angela has kind of given it to Kevin that he screwed up again.
And then there's some real Kevin Sass. Oh, it's great. Oh my gosh. He's like, I didn't realize I was doing something wrong. If I had, I would
have admitted it and stopped right away, he really leans in hard on this moment. And Oscar gives him
props. He's like, no, that was really good. You did a great job. Congratulations.
Jenna, immediately after the scene in the script, there's a very angry Angela talking head.
And it's pretty amazing because Angela is so furious that she breaks the fourth wall and
berates the camera documentary crew and then flashes them some of her shoulder.
Really?
太棒了。这个场景把我们带到了会计部，安吉拉有点责怪凯文他又搞砸了。然后有一些真正的凯文式傲慢。哦，太棒了。天哪。他说，我没意识到我在做错事。如果我意识到了，我会承认并立即停止，他真的在这个时刻表现得很强硬。奥斯卡给了他赞赏。他说，不，那真的很好。你做得很好。恭喜。珍娜，在剧本中这个场景之后，紧接着是一个非常愤怒的安吉拉的谈话头。这非常令人惊叹，因为安吉拉太愤怒了，以至于她打破了第四面墙，斥责了摄像纪录片组，然后向他们露出了她的一些肩膀。真的吗？
Yes, Sam, will you play it?
It's just so important for you to get your big story, isn't it?
To edit everything together, to make it look like there's a villain.
Well, there's not always a villain.
Sometimes there's just a hardworking, petite woman
trying to make a conscientious decision about the rest of her life.
Too boring?
Did I lose you?
是的，萨姆，你能播放一下吗？对你们来说，获得你们的大新闻真的很重要，不是吗？把所有东西剪辑在一起，让它看起来像是有个反派。好吧，并不总是有反派。有时只是一个努力工作的娇小女性，试图对她的余生做出一个认真的决定。太无聊了吗？我让你失望了吗？
Here, is this what you want?
Okay, that was amazing, but I have to say, I think it was right to cut it out because I don't know if we've ever had that much direct conversation with the documentary crew before.
If we've ever referred so much to what they're doing.
I was shocked when I watched it, Jenna, because she's like, is that what you want?
You're going to edit this together.
You're going to make a villain.
And also, it was a little bit too sophisticated for Angela Martin to understand the whole process of a documentary and how they tell us.
it through narration in these moments. So I think it was the right move to cut it, but I was shocked
给你，这是你想要的吗？好吧，那太棒了，但我必须说，我认为把它剪掉是正确的，因为我不知道我们以前是否和纪录片组有过那么多直接的对话。如果我们以前那么多次提到他们在做什么。当我观看它时，我感到震惊，珍娜，因为她说，这就是你想要的吗？你要把这个剪辑在一起。你要制造一个反派。而且，安吉拉·马丁理解纪录片的整个过程以及他们如何通过这些时刻的叙述来讲述故事，这有点太复杂了。所以我认为剪掉它是正确的举动，但我很震惊
when I saw it. I had to share. So Angela, I love this episode because there's just so much tension,
and it plays out so slowly over when or whether or not Andy is going to figure out that Angela's
having an affair. So he has this exclamation on the phone, and everyone's like,
but it's really just about the cake. He's just having an issue with the cake.
But this leads to that Dwight talking head.
Because Dwight is on guard this whole time.
He's like constantly leaping out of his chair.
Yeah.
当我看到它的时候。我必须分享。所以安吉拉，我喜欢这一集，因为有太多的紧张感，而且它在安迪是否会发现安吉拉有外遇的问题上缓慢地展开。所以他在电话里有这种惊叹，每个人都以为，但这其实只是关于蛋糕。他只是对蛋糕有意见。但这导致了那个德怀特的谈话头。因为德怀特一直处于戒备状态。他一直在从椅子上跳起来。是的。
And he kind of explains that there are these 40 rules that all Shrewboys must learn by the age of five.
And one of these rules is like, don't put your back to a man who you've wronged.
That's just one of the 40 rules.
Mm-hmm.
Don't turn your back on a bear or a dominant turkey during mating season.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things you shouldn't turn your back.
on. And then he has this little jingle that he sings. Now, Angela, is it true that Rain improvised that song?
他解释说，所有鼩鼱男孩在五岁之前都必须学习这40条规则。其中一条规则是，不要把背对着一个你亏待过的人。这只是40条规则中的一条。嗯哼。不要在交配季节把背对着熊或占主导地位的火鸡。是的。有很多东西你不应该把背对着。然后他唱了这个小顺口溜。现在，安吉拉，雷恩即兴创作那首歌是真的吗？
Oh, no. That was in the script. That was 100% written. They shared in the DVD commentary that
Rain was singing the jingle a few different ways. And then Dean asked Jen, Jen, how did you hear it when
you wrote it? She's sort of saying it her way. And they found it in the moment. So they found the
melody, but the words were written. The words are totally written. They're in the script. This is like
fabulous Jen Salada writing. They just improvised the melody. Got it. Well, now Dwight is going to signal
Angela to meet him in the hallway. He does this by moving his little bobblehead to the other side of his
desk. Yes. He's going to confront her. He wants her to tell Andy the truth. And Angela has a line,
Jenna, that really made me laugh. She's like, this is a terrible idea, one of your worst. And then he's like,
哦，不。那是在剧本里的。那是100%写好的。他们在DVD评论中分享说，雷恩用几种不同的方式唱这个顺口溜。然后迪恩问珍，珍，你写的时候是怎么听到的？她以她的方式唱出来。他们在那一刻找到了它。所以他们找到了旋律，但歌词是写好的。歌词完全是写好的。它们在剧本里。这是极好的珍·萨拉达的写作。他们只是即兴创作了旋律。明白了。好吧，现在德怀特要示意安吉拉在走廊见他。他通过把他的小摇头娃娃移到桌子的另一边来做到这一点。是的。他要和她对质。他要她告诉安迪真相。安吉拉有一句台词，珍娜，真的让我笑了。她说，这是一个糟糕的主意，你最糟糕的主意之一。然后他说，
just get it over with. And then Angela says, you're expanding on your worst idea. That just really made me laugh.
Well, Michael is leaving now, and he asks Andy to walk with him. Yeah, he's going to do it. He's going to do it. He can't
not do it. This is like true Michael. Like, he can't not. The scene is so funny. It's so funny.
I mean, it's so perfect. You know, I believe Angela originally in the scene, he is,
supposed to tell Andy before he got in his car? Yes, it's scripted that he tells him outside of the car.
But on the day, they came up with the idea that it would be really funny if Michael was in the car
and then he sort of says it through the window as he's driving away and that is so good. Yes. So in the
commentary, Dean said he had the idea in the moment that the scene takes place with Michael in the car.
快点结束吧。然后安吉拉说，你正在扩展你最糟糕的主意。那真的让我笑了。好吧，迈克尔现在要走了，他让安迪和他一起走。是的，他要做了。他要做了。他不能不做。这就像真正的迈克尔。就像，他不能不做。这个场景太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我的意思是，太完美了。你知道，我相信安吉拉最初在场景中，他应该在进车前告诉安迪？是的，剧本里写的是他在车外告诉他。但在当天，他们想出了一个主意，如果迈克尔在车里，然后他在开车离开时通过窗户说出来，那会非常有趣，这太棒了。是的。所以在评论中，迪恩说他在那一刻有了这个主意，场景发生在迈克尔在车里的时候。
And then Steve sort of built on that and was like, what if Michael really doesn't want to tell him? So it's kind of like as
he's pulling away. And then Dean said that Steve really peeled out of the parking lot. They did not
add that sound in in post. That's actually the car peeling away. Oh, that's amazing. Well,
we had a fan question from Maria M about this scene. She said, is there a production-related reason
why the vehicles in this episode all appear so dusty and dirty? And when I went back and looked at it,
yes, they're all covered in grime. Yeah, they're filthy. I asked Randy Cordray.
about it, and he said, yes, Maria. Great eye to detail, all of the cars were purposely dirtied by the
scenic painting crew using flour and water, and this was meant to simulate what cars might look like
然后史蒂夫在那基础上发挥，说，如果迈克尔真的不想告诉他会怎样？所以就像他正要开车离开时一样。然后迪恩说史蒂夫真的从停车场飞驰而去。他们没有在后期添加那个声音。那实际上是汽车飞驰而出的声音。哦，那太棒了。好吧，我们有一个来自玛丽亚·M的粉丝提问，关于这个场景。她说，这一集里的车辆看起来都那么灰尘仆仆和肮脏，有什么与制作相关的原因吗？当我回去看的时候，是的，它们都覆盖着污垢。是的，它们很脏。我问了兰迪·科德雷
during a typical Scranton winter from just road grime and salt. And snow. Yes. When snow gets dirty
looking, right? And it's on your car. Yes. And that the cars in the parking lot belonged to
to our crew members, and any crew member who volunteered to park their car in the lot got a free
car wash every Friday.
Oh, how about that?
So during the week, they'd have to drive around with a grimy car, but on the weekends,
you got a fresh, clean car.
Well, I think this is a good place to take a break because Andy knows the truth, and when we
关于这件事，他说，是的，玛丽亚。观察力真敏锐，所有的车都是由布景绘画组故意用面粉和水弄脏的，这是为了模拟汽车在典型的斯克兰顿冬天可能看起来的样子，来自道路污垢和盐。还有雪。是的。当雪看起来很脏的时候，对吧？而且它在你的车上。是的。而且停车场里的车属于我们的工作人员，任何自愿把车停在停车场的工作人员每周五都能得到一次免费洗车。哦，那怎么样？所以在这一周里，他们必须开着一辆肮脏的车，但在周末，你得到了一辆崭新的、干净的车。好吧，我认为这是一个休息的好地方，因为安迪知道了真相，当我们
come back, we'll talk about what he does.
Oh, man.
It's a lot.
This was some cringy stuff to watch.
We'll be right back.
All right, we are back, and guys, Meredith knew something big was going to happen today.
Now, she said that yesterday, but she was also right yesterday because her neighbor was murdered.
Oh, my gosh.
回来时，我们会谈谈他做了什么。天哪。这有很多内容。看这些东西真是让人尴尬。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，伙计们，梅雷迪思知道今天会发生大事。现在，她昨天就说了，但她昨天也说对了，因为她的邻居被谋杀了。天哪。
What is her life?
I don't know, but Meredith has the best, like, throwaway lines.
It's like her and creed.
Like, what the heck is their life?
It must have been so fun to write for them.
I know.
At 8 minutes, 42 seconds, we get a really good shot of Meredith in this episode, and she is wearing a sweater vest.
Yes.
她的生活是什么样的？我不知道，但梅雷迪思有最好的那种随口说出的台词。就像她和克里德一样。天哪，他们的生活到底是怎么回事？为他们写剧本一定很有趣。我知道。在8分42秒，我们得到了这一集中梅雷迪思的一个非常好的镜头，她穿着一件毛衣背心。是的。
Lady, I wore that same sweater vests to a press event with John Krasinski in New York.
What?
Yeah.
I walked on set this week we were shooting the duel and I looked at Kate dressed as Meredith and I thought, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Did I make a terrible mistake?
I thought it was fashionable.
I wore that same vest over this like big, poofy.
女士，我在纽约和约翰·卡拉辛斯基参加新闻发布会时穿了同一件毛衣背心。什么？是的。这周我们拍摄《决斗》时我走进片场，我看着打扮成梅雷迪思的凯特，我想，天哪。天哪。我犯了一个可怕的错误吗？我以为它很时尚。我把那件背心穿在了一件大大的、蓬松的
white blouse with big poofy shoulders. This was the style.
What? It was actually a really expensive vest. It was like Betsy Johnson or something.
Can we do a side by side of you and Meredith? We must. Jenna in real life has the same fashion choices as Meredith.
Lady, look. Here's a picture. Look at it. See? Look at it. Oh my God. First of all, you and John look 14 years old.
We have to put this photo in Office Lady's Stories.
You are wearing Meredith's sweater vest, and John looks like he could host Blues Clues.
He's in like a stripy polo.
Yeah.
白色衬衫外面，有大大的蓬松肩膀。这就是当时的风格。什么？它实际上是一件非常昂贵的背心。它好像是贝齐·约翰逊之类的。我们能把你和梅雷迪思做一个对比吗？我们必须这样做。珍娜在现实生活中和梅雷迪思有同样的时尚选择。女士，看。这是一张照片。看看它。看见了吗？看看它。天哪。首先，你和约翰看起来像14岁。我们必须把这张照片放进《办公室女士》的故事里。你穿着梅雷迪思的毛衣背心，而约翰看起来像他可以主持《布鲁的线索》。他穿着一件条纹马球衫。是的。
Oh, my God, you guys look 14 years old.
We were doing press at this NBC Experience store, showing off all the new office merchandise.
Meredith called.
She wants her sweater vest back.
Oh, my gosh.
And like I'd already done the event, you know?
Well, you could have heard a pin drop when Andy walked back into that bullpen and he goes over to Angela and says, we need to talk.
And she's like, we can talk right here.
天哪，你们看起来像14岁。我们在NBC体验店做新闻发布，展示所有新的办公室周边商品。梅雷迪思打来电话。她想要回她的毛衣背心。天哪。而且好像我已经参加完活动了，你知道吗？好吧，当安迪走回那个办公区并走到安吉拉身边说“我们需要谈谈”时，你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。她说，我们可以在这里谈。
And he's like, no, no.
Ed played it so real.
I was sweating.
I was sweating it.
Like, I felt it.
We went into that conference room and he shut the door.
And we were in there a long time.
And Ed broke my heart
他说，不，不。埃德演得太真实了。我在出汗。我在出汗。就像，我感觉到了。我们走进那个会议室，他关上了门。我们在里面待了很长时间。埃德伤了我的心
As Andy
When he was like, do you love him?
And I was really feeling all of this emotion
And then Angela has to make this plea
This plea to him to don't give up on us
And Jenna, it was all going great
Until we got to two words, formal chrysanthemums
I couldn't say it. Formal chrysanthemums.
作为安迪，当他说，你爱他吗？我真的感受到了所有的情绪，然后安吉拉必须做出这个恳求，这个恳求他不要放弃我们，珍娜，一切都很顺利，直到我们说到两个词，正式的菊花。我无法说出来。正式的菊花。
Formal chrysanthemums. I really had to break it down to be able to say it. But you need to say it like it's effortless.
But I literally was like going formal chrysanthemums.
You know what, lady, that is not anything having to do with your accent or you. I challenge anyone to say that word. I can't chrysanthemums.
Say it quickly.
Guys, and here's a formal chrysanthemum.
That was my best effort, by the way.
I mean, literally, Jen Salada had to come in the room and help me break it down.
But try saying it quickly while you're like throwing it away, like you have no problem saying it in a speech where you're pleading to save your relationship.
正式的菊花。我真的必须把它拆解开来才能说出来。但你需要说得好像毫不费力。但我真的就像在说“正式的菊花”。你知道吗，女士，这与你的口音或你无关。我挑战任何人说出那个词。我不能，菊花。快速说出来。伙计们，这是一个正式的菊花。顺便说一句，这是我最好的努力。我的意思是，字面上，珍·萨拉达不得不走进房间帮我把它拆解开。但试着在快速说的时候把它扔掉，就像你在恳求挽救你们的关系的演讲中说它没有问题一样。
And you know what?
It wouldn't have worked any other flower.
That's the funniest flower.
It had to be that.
I know.
Well, while this whole Andy and Angela scene is going to.
on in the conference room. There's a flip side to what's happening. It's everyone in the bullpen
watching. It was deleted for time. It's so great. And I really feel like Phyllis summed up the
你知道吗？换成任何其他花都不会奏效。那是最好笑的花。必须是那个。我知道。好吧，当整个安迪和安吉拉的场景在会议室里进行时。正在发生的事情有另一面。那是办公区里的每个人都在看。它因为时间原因被删除了。它太棒了。我真的觉得菲利斯总结了
whole moment perfectly. Phyllis, why is it taking so long? He found out his little angel's been
screwing the bead farming weirdo. He's trying to make it make sense in his brain. And then he's
going to come out here and kill you. Thank you, Phyllis. You're welcome. Oh, yeah, she got it.
I mean, that made me laugh really hard.
I wish it had stayed in.
Well, this takes us to corporate.
Andy and Angela are going to stay in the conference room.
They're not done.
整个时刻非常完美。菲利斯，为什么花了这么长时间？他发现他的小天使一直在和那个养鼩鼱的怪人做爱。他正试图让他的大脑理解这一点。然后他会出来杀了你。谢谢你，菲利斯。不客气。哦，是的，她明白了。我的意思是，那让我笑得很大声。我希望它能保留下来。好吧，这把我们带到了公司。安迪和安吉拉要留在会议室。他们还没谈完。
But meanwhile, we cut over to corporate and we see the reason why David Wallace is called Michael in.
He says to Michael, Scranton is outperforming the other branches.
Everyone else is struggling.
And we want to know, what are you doing right?
What is Michael doing so right?
I mean, everything in Michael lit up like a Christmas tree.
He's like, David Wallace wants advice from me?
Yeah.
但与此同时，我们切到公司，我们看到了大卫·华莱士叫迈克尔进来的原因。他对迈克尔说，斯克兰顿的表现超过了其他分部。其他人都在挣扎。我们想知道，你做对了什么？迈克尔做对了什么？我的意思是，迈克尔身上的一切都像圣诞树一样亮了起来。他说，大卫·华莱士想从我这里得到建议？是的。
And then he starts talking.
Oh, Jenna, I have to read it.
Can I please read it?
Please read it.
The minute he said, David, here it is.
My philosophy is basically this.
And this is something that I live by.
And I always have and I always will.
然后他开始说话。哦，珍娜，我必须读一下。我可以读一下吗？请读一下。他说的每一分钟，大卫，就是这样。我的哲学基本上是这样的。这是我所遵循的。我一直都是，而且我永远都会。
don't ever for any reason do anything to anyone for any reason ever no matter what no matter where
or who or who you are with or or where you are going or where you've been ever for any reason
whatsoever what is he saying what is he saying i went to the script this was not scripted
What? There was a different moment. There was the same thing where he sort of started to talk nonsense. I think Steve was also improvising here. I think he went off what Jen had. And then I think they let Steve do his thing. And now his talking head where he says, sometimes I start a sentence and I don't even know where it's going. I just find it along the way. That was 100% scripted. The improvisation.
Yes. That was all exactly scripted. But this answer to David, I don't.
I think was a little bit on the page and then they just let Steve play.
I love it.
This little scene between Michael and David Wallace was important story-wise because it's really
永远不要因为任何原因，做任何事给任何人，因为任何原因，永远，无论发生什么，无论在哪里，或者你是谁，或者你和谁在一起，或者你要去哪里，或者你去过哪里，永远，因为任何原因，无论如何。他在说什么？他在说什么？我看了剧本，这不是剧本写的。什么？有一个不同的时刻。有同样的事情，他开始胡言乱语。我想史蒂夫在这里也是即兴发挥。我想他脱离了珍写的内容。然后我想他们让史蒂夫做他自己的事。现在他的谈话头，他说，有时我开始一个句子，我甚至不知道它要去哪里。我只是在过程中找到它。那是100%写好的剧本。即兴创作。是的。那完全是按照剧本写的。但这个对大卫的回答，我不认为是在纸上的，然后他们只是让史蒂夫发挥。我喜欢它。迈克尔和大卫·华莱士之间的这个小场景在故事上很重要，因为它真的
starting to set up the economic struggle slash decline of Dunder Mifflin, which is going to
play out in future seasons as branches start closing as we get bought out by Sabre.
Spoiler alerts.
I guess you're supposed to say that first.
Yeah, that's supposed to come first.
And also, you start to learn that David Wallace might be in a precarious position.
Yeah.
So we made it a comedy moment with Michael suddenly giving advice to David Wallace.
开始设定邓德·米夫林的经济斗争/衰落，这将在未来的季节中展开，随着分部开始关闭，随着我们被赛博收购。剧透警告。我想你应该先说那个。是的，那应该先说。而且，你开始了解到大卫·华莱士可能处于一个不稳定的位置。是的。所以我们把它变成了一个喜剧时刻，迈克尔突然给大卫·华莱士建议。
But this was also setting up a broader story that we will play out.
In the DVD commentary, Dean said one of his notes for all of the Michael David scenes in this episode was,
no matter what, Michael won't leave the office, no matter what.
Well, that makes sense because he suggests they order some pasta.
And then my favorite thing is like after that pasta eating scene where Michael is still just going on and on and on, David Wallace kind of gets up and then Michael keeps eating his pasta.
And David is like, no, no, yes, go, I guess just finish your meal there.
Yeah, I mean, like, pats him on the shoulder and shuts the door and sits back down.
Well, when we get back to the office, Angela and Andy are still in the conference.
但这也在设定一个更广泛的故事，我们将展开。在DVD评论中，迪恩说他在这一集中所有迈克尔和大卫场景的笔记之一是，无论如何，迈克尔都不会离开办公室，无论如何。好吧，这说得通，因为他建议他们点一些意大利面。然后我最喜欢的是在那个吃意大利面的场景之后，迈克尔仍然在喋喋不休，大卫·华莱士站起来，然后迈克尔继续吃他的意大利面。大卫说，不，不，是的，走吧，我想就在那里吃完你的饭。是的，我的意思是，就像，拍拍他的肩膀，关上门，坐回去。好吧，当我们回到办公室时，安吉拉和安迪还在会议室里。
room. She needs him to know that her and Dwight did not do anything fancy sexually. Well, Dwight tells
Michael something very differently about their sex life earlier. Oh my gosh. I can't believe we didn't
bring that up. That made me laugh so hard, Angela. I know. Yes. Michael is all asking Dwight,
like, if you're crazy. Is she crazy? Crazy in the sack? Is she crazy? And Dwight's like, yes. And then
Michael is like, how? How is she crazy? And Jim is just standing there. Yeah, Jim is like, oh God,
No, no. And then Dwight says eager and flexible. Lady, is that in the script? Was that an improv?
It's 100% scripted. It was so good. All of those beats. That made me laugh all loud.
Some of John's reactions as Jim are improvised, but everything else is scripted.
她需要让他知道她和德怀特在性方面没有做任何花哨的事情。好吧，德怀特早些时候告诉迈克尔关于他们的性生活完全不同。天哪。我不敢相信我们没提这件事。那让我笑得太厉害了，安吉拉。我知道。是的。迈克尔一直在问德怀特，你是不是疯了。她疯了吗？在床上疯了吗？她疯了吗？德怀特说，是的。然后迈克尔说，怎么疯？她怎么疯了？吉姆就站在那里。是的，吉姆就像，哦天哪，不，不。然后德怀特说渴望和灵活。女士，那在剧本里吗？那是即兴发挥吗？它是100%写好的剧本。太棒了。所有那些节拍。那让我大声笑了出来。约翰作为吉姆的一些反应是即兴发挥的，但其他一切都是按剧本写的。
Well, Angela doesn't tell Andy any of that stuff. She just says she loves him. And when he leaves the conference room, he tells Dwight, it's over. It's over. And he means.
over between you and Angela, not me and Angela. He's still going to marry Angela. Well, Angela made a big case.
She was like, listen, we're at a crossroads here. Let's prove all these people wrong. Dwight makes a big
declaration that Bernard will never be her last name. They are going to stay together. He is not going to
give up. Jenna, this was a much longer scene. And when Dwight says a duel, we'll have a duel over
Angela, the winner gets Angela.
Stanley can't take it anymore.
He's going to call BS, and he has this great moment.
好吧，安吉拉没有告诉安迪任何那些事情。她只是说她爱他。当他离开会议室时，他告诉德怀特，结束了。结束了。他的意思是，你和安吉拉之间结束了，不是我和安吉拉。他还是要娶安吉拉。好吧，安吉拉提出了一个大理由。她说，听着，我们现在处于十字路口。让我们证明所有这些人都是错的。德怀特发表了一个大声明，伯纳德永远不会是她的姓氏。他们要在一起。他不会放弃。珍娜，这是一个长得多的场景。当德怀特说决斗时，我们将为安吉拉决斗，赢家得到安吉拉。斯坦利再也受不了了。他要叫停，他有这个伟大的时刻。
Okay, we're not doing that.
Hang on, Pam.
Andy, do you fully understand that the prize is Angela?
So help me, God, I do.
And Dwight, do you fully understand that the prize is Angela?
I do.
I say give them both guns.
Stanley.
好吧，我们不那样做。等等，帕姆。安迪，你完全明白奖品是安吉拉吗？上帝帮我，我明白。德怀特，你完全明白奖品是安吉拉吗？我明白。我说给他们俩枪。斯坦利。
Darwin, baby.
Darwin.
Darwin, baby, Darwin.
I just love that moment.
Even Pam turns to Angela and is like, you have to stop this.
But Angela says, I will respect the results of the duel.
So, yeah, I remember us shooting this moment, Jenna.
But in my mind, there was more to the scene.
达尔文，宝贝。达尔文。达尔文，宝贝，达尔文。我只是喜欢那个时刻。甚至帕姆转向安吉拉说，你必须停止这个。但安吉拉说，我会尊重决斗的结果。所以，是的，我记得我们拍摄这个时刻，珍娜。但在我的脑海里，这个场景还有更多内容。
I went to the script.
And there was an alt of this moment where Pam confronts Angela.
It didn't make it in, and you have a whole speech, and I called it preach, Pam!
This takes place in the break room.
Okay, Angela.
What?
You have to put a stop to this.
I admit, at first, I was blaming you for being selfish and dishonest, but then I decided to put myself in your shoes.
我看了剧本。这个时刻有一个替代版本，帕姆和安吉拉对质。它没有被放进去，你有一整段演讲，我称之为“布道，帕姆！”这发生在休息室。好吧，安吉拉。什么？你必须停止这个。我承认，起初，我责怪你自私和不诚实，但我决定设身处地为你着想。
I didn't ask you to do that.
I get it.
You're having a hard time choosing between Dwight and Andy.
for reasons that you must have about that.
But you have to make a decision, Angela.
Who would you rather go home to at night?
Who would you rather wake up with in the morning?
Marriage is a big deal, Angela.
我没让你那样做。我明白了。你在德怀特和安迪之间做出选择很困难。因为你一定有关于那个的原因。但你必须做出决定，安吉拉。你晚上更愿意和谁回家？你早上更愿意和谁一起醒来？婚姻是一件大事，安吉拉。
Who do you see as the father of your children?
Who are you most proud of?
Who's most accepting of your quirkiness?
I don't see how any of that matters now.
Why not?
Two men are about to fight for my hand.
When it's over, I will respect one of them and pity the other.
Decision made.
你认为谁是你孩子的父亲？你最为谁感到骄傲？谁最能接受你的古怪？我不明白那现在有什么关系。为什么不？两个男人正要为我的手而战。当它结束时，我会尊重其中一个，并怜悯另一个。决定做出了。
Wow.
Like, really tried to show up for Angela in this moment.
Tried to empathize with her.
And what, you know, you guys are hearing it.
But if you watch it, if you go to the deleted scenes on the DVD, you see all of this emotion go across my face.
I'm clearly torn.
Yeah.
And it just really shows.
哇。就像，真的试图在这个时刻为安吉拉挺身而出。试图同情她。而且，你知道，你们听到了。但如果你看它，如果你去DVD上的删除场景，你会看到所有的情绪在我脸上闪过。我显然很纠结。是的。而且它真的展示了
something you don't get to see that much in this. You only see little moments that Angela is really struggling.
Yeah. Well, Angela, when I was trading messages with Jen Salada about this episode, she was very complimentary of your performance.
Oh. She said that this episode was tricky and a lot rested on how your character would react to these two men dueling over her.
She said she was really worried. Like, how do you convince people?
that you would accept the results of a duel.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
And she said, you know, there was this scene that really shows you stuffing down your real feelings.
一些你在这个节目中看不到太多的东西。你只看到安吉拉真正挣扎的小时刻。是的。好吧，安吉拉，当我与珍·萨拉达交流关于这一集的信息时，她对你的表演非常赞赏。哦。她说这一集很棘手，很多都取决于你的角色将如何对这两个为她决斗的男人做出反应。她说她真的很担心。就像，你怎么说服人们？你会接受决斗的结果。这太疯狂了。是的。她说，你知道，有这个场景真的展示了你压抑你真实的感觉。
But she said that you were able to play it so perfectly in just your one line in the bullpen.
We so believed that your character would accept the results of a duel that it
It grounds the whole episode. And she was so grateful for your performance.
Oh, my gosh. That's so nice. Thank you, Jen. Well, you know, what I thought about Angela is that she really loves Dwight. She really thinks Andy is a better partner for her, like socially, sort of acceptable and all of that. And she's really struggling about what's the right thing to do in her life. And the duel for her is actually a relief because now she doesn't have to decide.
To her, this is like an institution that will decide for her, and she's off the hook. And I think that's why she was so willing to accept it.
We had some people right in wondering, were you secretly rooting for one man over the other? Do you think Angela Martin was secretly rooting for one person?
I think she was hoping Dwight would win. For her, I just have this feeling that on paper, Andy Bernard is more presentable to her family, right? And makes more sense.
to Angela Martin's family
但她说你能够在办公区里只用你的一句台词就完美地演绎出来。我们非常相信你的角色会接受决斗的结果，它为整集奠定了基础。她非常感谢你的表演。天哪。那太好了。谢谢你，珍。好吧，你知道，关于安吉拉，我想的是她真的爱德怀特。她真的认为安迪对她来说是一个更好的伴侣，比如在社交上，某种程度上是可以接受的等等。她真的在为她生活中什么是正确的事情而挣扎。对她来说，决斗实际上是一种解脱，因为现在她不必决定了。对她来说，这就像一个会为她决定的机构，她摆脱了困境。我认为这就是她为什么如此愿意接受它的原因。我们有一些人写信来想知道，你是否在暗中支持其中一个男人？你认为安吉拉·马丁在暗中支持某个人吗？我想她希望德怀特赢。对我来说，我只是有这种感觉，在纸面上，安迪·伯纳德对她的家人来说更体面，对吧？而且更有意义。对安吉拉·马丁的家人来说
and that they would be more accepting
and more willing to embrace
Andy Bernard than Dwight Shrewt.
And so I feel like she could go to her family
and be like, well, Dwight bested him in a duel.
So, you know, clearly Dwight is the dominant man.
And I have no...
And your whole family would accept
而且他们会比德怀特·舒特更接受、更愿意拥抱安迪·伯纳德。所以我感觉她可以去告诉她的家人，好吧，德怀特在决斗中打败了他。所以，你知道，显然德怀特是占主导地位的男人。而且我没有……而且你的整个家庭都会接受
the results of the duel.
Yes, and I have to go with that.
So, you know, I mean, I know
we all thought Andy was the one.
But I don't think Angela ever thought
Andy was the one.
And so I think she thinks,
thinks her family would accept it too. Is that crazy? But that's what I was thinking. Yeah. So she's rooting for
决斗的结果。是的，我必须接受那个。所以，你知道，我的意思是，我知道我们都认为安迪是那个人。但我不认为安吉拉曾经认为安迪是那个人。所以我认为她认为，认为她的家人也会接受它。那很疯狂吗？但那就是我在想的。是的。所以她在支持
Dwight to win this duel because she loves him more and because it would help gain acceptance with her
family. Exactly. Well, this duel is happening. It is happening in the parking lot at 4 p.m.
Bring the weapon of your choice. Yeah. So it's 4 o'clock. The duel is beginning.
Dwight's outside in the parking lot. He's yelling. Andy, where are you? You know?
He's like, are you a coward?
Everyone else is upstairs watching from the conference room.
Angela's saying, I can't believe two men are fighting over me.
And then Kelly, like, has a dig.
德怀特赢得这场决斗，因为她更爱他，而且因为这有助于获得她家人的认可。正是如此。好吧，这场决斗正在发生。它正在下午4点在停车场发生。带上你选择的武器。是的。所以是4点钟。决斗开始了。德怀特在停车场外面。他在大喊。安迪，你在哪？你知道吗？他说，你是个懦夫吗？其他人都在楼上从会议室观看。安吉拉说，我不敢相信两个男人在为我而战。然后凯利，就像，挖苦了一下。
She's like, well, I guess when you're old, you run out of options or something like that.
I thought that was really funny.
Yeah.
Oscar doesn't think Andy's going to show, and they're actually kind of placing bets.
And Kevin's like, come on.
But then Dwight sees a note on some bushes.
Yeah.
He goes over to read it.
她说，好吧，我想当你老了，你的选择就用完了之类的。我觉得那真的很有趣。是的。奥斯卡不认为安迪会出现，他们实际上在下注。凯文说，来吧。但随后德怀特在灌木丛上看到了一张纸条。是的。他走过去读它。
What is this?
Yeah, what's this note about?
While he's reading it, Andy does show up very slowly, very quietly.
Yes.
In his Prius.
Well, you know, Jenna, Jen had that one sentence that she had to write this whole episode off of, right?
Yeah.
About the duel.
这是什么？是的，这张纸条是关于什么的？当他在读的时候，安迪确实出现了，非常缓慢，非常安静。是的。在他的普锐斯里。好吧，你知道，珍娜，珍有一句话，她必须写完这一整集，对吧？是的。关于决斗。
This was Paul Lieberstein's idea about the Prius.
He said, if you go under five miles an hour, it's totally silent.
And so this is the weapon Andy chooses.
Yes.
He is going to pin Dwight up against the bushes.
He's going to crush him.
But really, he's only crushing, like, from his kneecaps down.
Yeah, but he's pinned.
这是保罗·利伯斯坦关于普锐斯的想法。他说，如果你在时速五英里以下，它是完全静音的。所以这就是安迪选择的武器。是的。他要把德怀特钉在灌木丛上。他要压碎他。但实际上，他只是从膝盖以下压碎他。是的，但他被钉住了。
I mean, Dwight can't move.
Dwight can't hit him with his bike chain anymore.
Yeah.
So he starts slamming it on the hood of the car.
They're screaming at each other.
At 18 minutes, 16 seconds,
Rain shared on the DVD that during this whole screaming match
between the two of them, they improvise for about 40 minutes. Dean said at least 40 minutes.
我的意思是，德怀特动不了。德怀特不能再用他的自行车链打他了。是的。所以他开始把它猛撞在车盖上。他们在大声尖叫。在18分16秒，雷恩在DVD上分享说，在他们两人之间的整个尖叫比赛中，他们即兴发挥了大约40分钟。迪恩说至少40分钟。
Just insults and banter back and forth at each other. Dean said there was so much good stuff.
Oh, I wish we could see that. The 40 minutes of them yelling at each other. I would watch it.
Sure. They're probably amazing. Well, we got a lot of questions about how did we do this scene? How did we do this stunt?
Who was driving? Yada yada. Well, I talked to Dean and he said this was really complicated because we had to shoot this scene over two different days from three different locations.
First, we shot in the parking lot with Rain and Ed. They performed the whole thing. We shot it.
and the rest of us were upstairs in Paul's office looking out that window and the camera could whip up to us.
In real time.
只是互相侮辱和调侃。迪恩说有很多好东西。哦，我希望我们能看到那个。他们互相大喊大叫的40分钟。我会看的。当然。他们可能很棒。好吧，我们收到了很多关于我们是如何做这个场景的问题？我们是如何做这个特技的？谁在开车？等等等等。好吧，我和迪恩谈过，他说这真的很复杂，因为我们必须在两天内从三个不同的地点拍摄这个场景。首先，我们在停车场和雷恩、埃德一起拍摄。他们表演了整个过程。我们拍摄了它。而我们其他人都在楼上保罗的办公室里看着窗外，摄像机可以扫向我们。实时地。实时地。
We watched all of it.
Then they moved the cameras up to Paul's office to get really tight shots out of the window onto the action below.
And Rain and Ed had to do it all over again just to get a few little shots through the window.
But then on a different day, we shot inside the actual Dunder Mifflin conference room, and this time we had to be careful to not shoot out the window because there was nothing there. It was just a backdrop.
And that we were basically looking at nothing, but Dean was shouting out all the action that had happened the day before.
Right.
He said this was the moment when being an editor on the show really helped him.
He had kind of cut this whole thing together with a shot list inside his head.
我们看了所有这些。然后他们把摄像机移到保罗的办公室，从窗户拍到下面动作的非常紧凑的镜头。雷恩和埃德不得不重新做一遍，只是为了通过窗户得到几个小镜头。但后来在不同的一天，我们在实际的邓德·米夫林会议室里拍摄，这一次我们必须小心不要拍到窗外，因为那里什么都没有。它只是一个背景。而且我们基本上什么都没看，但迪恩在大声喊出前一天发生的所有动作。对。他说这是作为节目编辑真正帮助他的时刻。他在脑海里用镜头列表剪辑了整个事情。
and he just kept telling people, trust me, trust me, trust me.
He could see it, right? He could see it. He could see the whole thing. He said he planned all of these
whip pan cuts between the window, between us, all of it. And when he got in the editing room,
because he edited this episode as well, it actually did all come together and it looked really,
really seamless. Well, you have to think that Randy Cordray was like, I knew it. I knew it.
Yes. That Dean's editing was going to come.
coming to play here. This is why Dean has to direct this episode. But he did say it was a little
grueling for the actors because we had to play these same moments over and over and over again
他只是不断告诉人们，相信我，相信我，相信我。他能看到它，对吧？他能看到它。他能看到整个事情。他说他计划了所有这些在窗户之间、我们之间、所有这些之间的扫拍剪辑。当他进入剪辑室时，因为他也剪辑了这一集，它确实全部组合在一起，看起来非常、非常无缝。好吧，你必须认为兰迪·科德雷就像，我知道。我知道。是的。迪恩的剪辑会发挥作用。这就是为什么迪恩必须导演这一集。但他确实说这对演员来说有点折磨人，因为我们必须一遍又一遍地表演这些相同的时刻
more so than we normally do. And we had to make it seem like we were doing it for the first time
every time. Now, as for the stunt, Randy told us that Ed actually drove the Prius,
silently through the parking lot. He said they had stunt doubles standing by for the actual
moment of impact. They thought that they would have a stunt driver actually drive into a stunt
Dwight. Right. And then after they were kind of squished, they would place Rain into the bushes.
And Ed into the car. Yes. But then on the commentary, didn't Rain say they just kind of ended up doing it
themselves? Actually, the commentary was Rain Wilson, Jen Salada, Dean Holland, and Rusty Mahmood, who was our first
assistant director.
比我们平时做的更多。而且我们必须让它看起来像是我们第一次做一样。现在，至于特技，兰迪告诉我们，埃德实际上是静音地开着普锐斯穿过停车场。他说他们有特技替身在旁边准备好迎接实际的撞击时刻。他们认为他们会让一个特技司机实际开车撞向一个特技德怀特。对。然后当他们被压扁后，他们会把雷恩放进灌木丛里。把埃德放进车里。是的。但后来在评论中，雷恩不是说他们只是最终自己做了吗？实际上，评论是雷恩·威尔森、珍·萨拉达、迪恩·霍兰德和拉斯蒂·马哈茂德，他是我们的第一助理导演。
And they discussed that Ed actually drove into rain very slowly and that it totally worked.
And those takes of those guys actually doing it were their favorite.
So those were the ones they used.
And they did not use takes with the stunt people.
Well, we also got a fan question from Samantha T who wanted to know what was up with the fence.
Like what was on the other side of it?
Was it padding?
Was it an actual fence?
他们讨论说埃德实际上非常缓慢地撞向雷恩，而且它完全奏效了。那些他们实际做的镜头是他们最喜欢的。所以那些是他们使用的。而且他们没有使用特技人员的镜头。好吧，我们还收到了一个来自萨曼莎·T的粉丝提问，她想知道栅栏是怎么回事？就像它的另一边是什么？是衬垫吗？是一个真正的栅栏吗？
Was the bumper of the car padded?
Was Rain really being squashed?
Well, it was the real bumper of the car.
And then Rain sent in an audio clip
to tell us a little bit about the bushes.
Oh, I'm so glad you guys are doing the dual.
Fantastic, one of my very favorite episodes.
And I always loved those episodes
汽车保险杠有衬垫吗？Rain真的被压扁了吗？嗯，那确实是汽车真正的保险杠。然后Rain发来一段音频，告诉我们一些关于灌木丛的事。哦，我很高兴你们在做双人对决。太棒了，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我一直很喜欢那些剧集
where Dwight and Handy got to go head to head.
I just loved that subplot of that.
that tension and ed helms is so funny in this episode but you know what it reminded me of is in
college we studied clowning and camedia del arté and it really is classic old old comedy like back from
comedia delarte and the greeks and ancient clowning of two idiots going at it over absurd
shi. And in this case, love and a Prius. It was so much fun to shoot. I don't remember a lot of
specifics about it, but I remember the hedge had a lot of give in it, so you could really
pretend like you were pinned. But it was just a big mass of vines, and it was actually very
Dwight和Andy针锋相对的场景。我真的很喜欢那个次要情节。那种紧张感，Ed Helms在这集里太搞笑了，但你知道这让我想起了什么吗？在大学里我们学习过小丑表演和意大利即兴喜剧，这真的是经典的古老喜剧，就像意大利即兴喜剧、古希腊戏剧和古代小丑表演一样，两个白痴为了荒谬的事情争斗。在这种情况下，是为了爱情和一辆普锐斯。拍摄过程非常有趣。我不记得很多具体细节，但我记得树篱很有弹性，所以你可以真的假装自己被困住了。但它只是一大团藤蔓，实际上非常
soft and comfortable. And I love that line about the bears in Scranton. It's so fantastic.
So I guess rain was quite comfortable being pinned against the bushes,
No complaints.
Well, I can tell you about those big giant hedges.
One time, Brian in a scene as Kevin nudged me, he thought it was a nudge.
I went flying into them.
I don't know if you remember that.
I can't remember what episode, but I can attest to the fact that it's a very deep, dense,
柔软舒适。我喜欢关于斯克兰顿熊的那句台词。太棒了。所以我猜Rain被困在灌木丛中感觉很舒服，没有抱怨。嗯，我可以告诉你关于那些巨大的树篱的事。有一次，Brian在扮演Kevin时推了我一下，他以为那只是轻轻一推。我直接飞进了树篱里。我不知道你是否还记得。我不记得是哪一集了，但我可以证明它非常深、非常茂密，
very sort of a hedge you could fall into without getting to the other side.
Uh-huh.
Well, the hedges might have been a good thing for rain.
mean they were a nice soft place to land, but they actually caused a little bit of a headache for our
production. So Rusty Mahmoud, our first assistant director, shared on the DVD commentary
that we had about six hours a day to film these parking lot scenes. That's what they had allotted
for the time. And by the time we got to the parking lot scenes on the first day of filming,
那种你掉进去都到不了另一边的树篱。嗯哼。嗯哼。好吧，树篱对Rain来说可能是件好事。我的意思是它们是一个柔软的着陆点，但它们确实给我们的制作带来了一点麻烦。所以我们的第一助理导演Rusty Mahmoud在DVD评论中分享说，我们每天大约有六个小时的时间来拍摄这些停车场场景。这就是他们分配的时间。当我们第一天拍摄到达停车场场景时，
those big hedges had cast a shadow over half of the parking lot. If you go and watch,
you'll see.
Okay.
There's a huge shadow.
Well, now guess what?
We needed to match that shadow exactly the second day we filmed.
Yeah.
Right?
那些大树篱已经在停车场的一半区域投下了阴影。如果你去看看，你就会发现。好吧。有一个巨大的阴影。嗯，现在你猜怎么着？我们需要在第二天拍摄时完全匹配那个阴影。是的。对吧？
So in order to do that, they had to create this fake shadow.
We have faky shadow.
Faky shadow.
They used giant 20 by 20 bounce cards and positioned them behind the hedges on the street
so that the shadow would cast and match each day we filmed in the parking lot.
Gosh, those are things you just don't think about.
I know.
所以为了做到这一点，他们必须制造这种虚假的阴影。我们有虚假阴影。虚假阴影。虚假阴影。他们使用了巨大的20乘20英尺的反光板，并将它们放置在街道上的树篱后面，这样阴影就能投射出来，并与我们在停车场拍摄的每一天相匹配。天哪，这些事情你根本想不到。我知道。
But this is the amazing thing about your crew.
Someone was like, oh, hold up.
That shadow's not going to match.
We've got to recreate a shadow.
Amazing.
Well, Faky Shadow wasn't the only faky thing we had in this scene.
We also had faky bicycle chain.
Faky bicycle chain.
但这就是你们剧组令人惊叹的地方。有人说，哦，等等。那个阴影对不上。我们必须重新制造一个阴影。太神奇了。好吧，虚假阴影并不是我们在这个场景中唯一的虚假东西。我们还有虚假自行车链。虚假自行车链。
That's right.
Clearly Rain could not whip around a real bicycle chain.
So Phil Shea had a rubber bicycle chain made,
and that's what Rain used as Dwight to hit the Prius and wave around.
So obviously a rubber bicycle chain is not going to make the same sound as a real bicycle chain on metal.
So all the sounds you hear are put in post, that whopping sound.
Except for the car horn.
Oh, yeah.
没错。显然Rain不可能挥舞真正的自行车链。所以Phil Shea制作了一条橡胶自行车链，这就是Rain作为Dwight用来敲打普锐斯并挥舞的东西。所以很明显，橡胶自行车链发出的声音和金属上的真实自行车链发出的声音是不一样的。所以你听到的所有声音都是后期制作的，那种呼呼声。除了汽车喇叭声。哦，是的。
Ed was really blaring the horn.
I know.
Poor Rain.
I know, but he was really having fun with it too because he'd wait and blare it right when Rain, like,
started to talk.
Well, all of this mayhem is going on, and Jim has a talking head where he's just kind of
standing there, and you can hear it all in the background.
Oh, yeah.
Ed真的在狂按喇叭。我知道。可怜的Rain。我知道，但他自己也玩得很开心，因为他会等着，就在Rain开始说话的时候按喇叭。好吧，所有这些混乱都在发生，Jim有一个谈话头镜头，他只是站在那里，你可以听到背景里所有的声音。哦，是的。
So good.
Dean told me that they came up with that idea on the day.
He said that as he and Jen Salata were standing there, just listening to these two guys go
on, he thought it would be really funny to add that.
So he and Jen came up with that, and they positioned John.
and they just kind of added that in the moment.
It's so perfect because it's the voice of reason.
It's this totally normal, rational person reacting to this moment of chaos.
太棒了。Dean告诉我，他们是在当天想出这个主意的。他说，当他和Jen Salata站在那里，听着这两个家伙争吵时，他觉得加上这个会非常有趣。所以他和Jen想出了这个主意，他们安排了John的位置。他们只是在那个瞬间把它加了进去。这太完美了，因为这是理性的声音。这是一个完全正常、理智的人对这一混乱时刻的反应。
And I feel like it lets the audience take a breath and be like, oh, yeah, this is crazy.
Well, in this argument, Andy ends up revealing that he and Angela have had sex,
which is something that Dwight did not know.
Well, yeah, he says, I can't believe she's been sleeping with you this whole time and she's only slept with me twice.
I made a sex tracker.
Oh my God.
I did.
Oh, no.
我觉得这让观众可以喘口气，心想，哦，是的，这太疯狂了。嗯，在这场争论中，Andy最终透露他和Angela发生了性关系，这是Dwight所不知道的。嗯，是的，他说，我不敢相信她一直和你睡在一起，而她只和我睡过两次。我做了一个性行为追踪器。天哪。我真的做了。哦，不。
Here's what I'm going to say, Angela.
Oh.
In the business trip episode, Andy told Oscar he had never had sex with Angela.
In the surplus, Andy says he has seen Angela naked zero times.
Mm-hmm.
So, we have to imagine that either they've had sex twice since.
the surplus, or they've had sex twice since business trip, but that while having sex, he never saw Angela naked. Which one do you think it is? Fully clothed sex or naked sex recently? You know what? I believe both. I believe that he could possibly have had sex with her, but she wouldn't let him see her naked, like she'd have some kind of like long gown on. But I also can believe that
After Dwight hoodwinked her into this fake wedding that she was furious, and she went and had some revenge sex.
Angela，我要说的是。哦。在《商务旅行》那一集中，Andy告诉Oscar他从未和Angela发生过性关系。在《盈余》中，Andy说他零次见过Angela裸体。嗯哼。所以，我们必须想象要么他们在那之后发生了两次性关系，要么他们在《商务旅行》之后发生了两次性关系，但在发生性关系时，他从未见过Angela裸体。你觉得是哪一种？穿着衣服做爱还是最近裸体做爱？你知道吗？我相信两者都有。我相信他可能和她发生过性关系，但她不会让他看到她裸体，比如她会穿某种长袍。但我也相信，在Dwight用这场假婚礼欺骗她之后，她非常愤怒，于是她去进行了报复性行为。
I think that's most likely. That's when they had their sex.
Yeah.
Well, Andy is going to return to his desk.
Dwight returns to his desk.
They're both crestfallen.
Yeah.
I mean, Dwight feels betrayed and Andy feels betrayed.
But who won the duel, Angela's standing there.
我觉得那最有可能。那就是他们发生性关系的时候。是的。好吧，Andy要回到他的办公桌。Dwight回到他的办公桌。他们都垂头丧气。是的。我的意思是，Dwight感到被背叛了，Andy也感到被背叛了。但谁赢了这场决斗，Angela站在那里。
She hears Andy make a phone call.
He cancels the wedding cake.
Yeah, it's the one that was in the shape of a sailboat.
Yeah, that one.
That wedding cake.
Jen said they did have an alt cake line where he would say it was the one in the shape of the letter C for Cornell.
Oh, I was like for cat.
I know.
她听到Andy打了一个电话。他取消了婚礼蛋糕。是的，就是那个帆船形状的。是的，那个。那个婚礼蛋糕。Jen说他们确实有一个备用蛋糕台词，他会说那是Cornell大学字母C形状的。哦，我还以为是猫的形状。我知道。
But they went with sailboat.
Then Angela looks to Dwight.
Did he win?
He puts his bobblehead in the trash.
Jenna, there was a deleted scene that comes after this where Angela goes up to Pam and she's teary-eyed like her voice is wavering.
And she says, can you give me a right home from work today?
Because I no longer have a right home.
Yeah.
但他们最终选择了帆船。然后Angela看向Dwight。他赢了吗？他把他的摇头娃娃扔进了垃圾桶。Jenna，这之后有一个被删减的场景，Angela走到Pam身边，她眼含泪水，声音颤抖。她说，你今天能顺路载我回家吗？因为我没有车回家了。是的。
And Pam says yes.
And then her and Jim give Angela a ride home.
home. Oh, my God. This car ride, we did shoot this scene. It's in the deleted scenes. Angela just
barks directions angrily at Jim. And then she starts sobbing in the back seat and then she's angry
again. Well, I'll never forget shooting this scene, Angela, because, I mean, this was a whole location
day for us, you know? We had this location that was your house and we just dropped you off outside.
But they have this really funny joke that there would be like a dozen cats in your window staring out the window at you expectantly as we drop you off.
And it was so funny.
Pam说好。然后她和Jim载Angela回家。天哪。这次车程，我们确实拍了这个场景。它在被删减的片段里。Angela只是愤怒地对Jim大喊方向。然后她开始在后座啜泣，接着又变得愤怒。好吧，我永远不会忘记拍摄这个场景，Angela，因为，我的意思是，这对我们来说是整整一天的外景拍摄，你知道吗？我们有这个作为你家的外景地，我们只是把你放在外面。但他们有一个非常有趣的笑话，就是当你下车时，你的窗户里会有十几只猫期待地盯着你看。这太搞笑了。
It was so funny.
I remember they had to get a house with like sort of a big front window, like a bay window that all the cats could be in so that we could see them from the street.
But then you guys, as we were trading messages with Randy Cordray about this episode, he sent us.
The casting sheet of the cats and all their headshots.
It's a sheet of like cat headshots.
Yes, you guys.
And here are the names of the 12 cats that played Angela's cats.
Potato.
太搞笑了。我记得他们必须找一栋有大前窗的房子，比如凸窗，这样所有的猫都能待在里面，我们就能从街上看到它们。但后来你们，当我们和Randy Cordray交流这一集的信息时，他发给了我们。猫的选角表和它们所有的头像。那是一张猫的头像表。是的，你们。以下是扮演Angela猫的12只猫的名字。Potato。
Prada.
Echo.
Flame.
Prophet.
Whisper.
Milkman.
Sushi.
Roswell.
Prada。Echo。Flame。Prophet。Whisper。Milkman。Sushi。Roswell。
Harvey.
Hannah.
And Milton.
And Roswell looks just like Sunny Cat.
He does.
My cat.
Yeah.
Harvey。Hannah。Hannah。还有Milton。而且Roswell看起来就像Sunny Cat。确实。我的猫。是的。
We have to put that photo in stories.
And also, Randy sent us the photo of Angela Martin's house.
Yes.
So unfortunately, the scene was deleted, but the cats can get their moment of fame.
And we got to do a driving scene together.
We did.
It's very cute because at the end, after we drop you off, Pam turns to Jim and she says,
you know what, I'll call her later to check up on her.
我们必须把那张照片发到故事里。而且，Randy还发给了我们Angela Martin家的照片。是的。所以很遗憾，那个场景被删减了，但猫咪们可以获得属于它们的成名时刻。我们还一起拍了一场开车戏。我们拍了。这非常可爱，因为最后，当我们把你放下后，Pam转向Jim说，你知道吗，我稍后会给她打电话关心一下她。
And Jim says, she'll hang up on you.
Yes.
And Pam says, I know.
Well, that would have been our alt tag, right?
The car ride instead of Jim collecting Dwight's weapons.
But also, right at the end, Michael had a great talking head.
Yeah, he's standing on the streets of New York.
And he just sort of says, you know, exciting things can happen when you leave Scranton.
Jim说，她会挂断你的电话。是的。Pam说，我知道。好吧，那本来会是我们的备用结尾，对吧？开车送她回家，而不是Jim收集Dwight的武器。但同样，在最后，Michael有一个很棒的谈话头镜头。是的，他站在纽约的街头。他只是说，你知道，当你离开斯克兰顿，令人兴奋的事情就会发生。
Just kind of sums up this storyline for him.
Well, got a little tidbit from Randy.
I didn't notice it the first time I watched it, but in hindsight, it was obvious to me.
Oh, yeah.
This scene was a cheat.
Steve was not in New York.
Steve was shot on a green screen, and we digitally added the office building scene behind him.
Randy said we hired this New York-based cinematographer named Alan Pierce to go out and shoot the exterior of a New York office building with people walking by.
这算是总结了他的这条故事线。嗯，从Randy那里得到了一点小道消息。我第一次看的时候没注意到，但事后看来，这对我来说很明显。哦，是的。这个场景是作弊的。Steve当时不在纽约。Steve是在绿幕前拍摄的，我们数字合成了他身后的办公大楼场景。Randy说我们雇了一位纽约的摄影师Alan Pierce去拍摄纽约办公大楼的外景，路人走过。
Randy said it was this awesome shot, but we ran into a problem with the cameras on our end.
So for all you techies out there, we would shoot our show on a Sony 900 digital camera.
It was a very early generation digital camcorder.
And I guess these cameras had very poor color latitude.
Oh, sure, Jenna.
You know, you know.
And when it's not good, it can be tough.
I mean, we know.
Randy说这是一个很棒的镜头，但我们的摄像机出了点问题。所以对于你们这些技术宅，我们用索尼900数字摄像机拍摄我们的节目。那是非常早期一代的数字摄像机。我猜这些摄像机的色彩宽容度很差。哦，当然，Jenna。你知道的，你知道。当它不好时，会很棘手。我的意思是，我们知道。
Oh, yeah. How many times have I struggled with my color latitude? So many.
It does not do well shooting on green screen. And Randy said that's why we did it so infrequently.
Now, normally, we would just find someplace in downtown L.A. to double for New York. But I noticed on the
call sheets that we only had Steve for two and a half days this week. He worked Monday,
Tuesday and part of Wednesday, and the whole rest of our shoot was really dedicated to that complicated
parking lot scene. I asked Randy about it. He said he doesn't know exactly why we chose to go
green screen, but he has to imagine that we just simply did not have time to go downtown and get
that shot because it was a complicated shoot week. Well, I didn't catch it on my first watch,
哦，是的。我多少次为我的色彩宽容度而挣扎？太多次了。它在绿幕拍摄时表现不好。Randy说这就是为什么我们很少这样做。现在，通常我们会找洛杉矶市中心的某个地方来代替纽约。但我注意到在通告单上，我们这周只有Steve两天半的时间。他周一、周二和周三的一部分时间在工作，我们拍摄的其余时间真的都投入到了那个复杂的停车场场景中。我问了Randy。他说他不知道我们为什么选择绿幕，但他猜想我们只是没有时间去市中心拍摄那个镜头，因为那是一个拍摄任务很重的周。好吧，我第一次看的时候没发现，
but I really did on the second one. Me too. I was like, oh, that's a faky backdrop. There you.
have it. Faky building, faky shadow, faky bicycle chain, real feelings, guys. That's the duel.
That pretty much sums up the duel. All right. Well, thank you to everyone who contributed to this
episode. Thank you, Ryan Coe, for calling in and giving us the story of your tragic fall. Yes,
thank you, Ryan. And we're going to be back here next week, guys. We have Prince Family Paper. I'm going to be
honest, I do not remember the plot of that one.
Who's Prince? Who are they?
We're going to find out next week.
但在第二次看的时候真的发现了。我也是。我当时想，哦，那是虚假的背景。这就是了。虚假建筑、虚假阴影、虚假自行车链，真实的情感，伙计们。这就是《决斗》。这基本总结了《决斗》。好了。好吧，感谢所有为这一集做出贡献的人。谢谢你，Ryan Coe，打电话来告诉我们你那次悲惨跌倒的故事。是的，谢谢你，Ryan。我们下周会回来，伙计们。我们要讲《Prince家族纸业》。老实说，我不记得那一集的剧情了。Prince是谁？他们是谁？我们下周就会知道。
We're going to find out.
I feel like a real audience member. I don't know what's coming.
I'm sure I'll remember after I watch the episode, but I can't wait.
Hopefully.
I hope so.
See you guys. Have a great one.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
我们会知道的。我觉得自己像个真正的观众。我不知道接下来会发生什么。我相信看完那一集我就会想起来，但我等不及了。希望如此。再见，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela
McKinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office
Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratt.
本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela McKinsey制作。我们的高级制片人是Matt Beagle。我们的第二杯剧集由Molly Nugent制作。我们的音频工程师是Sam Pfeiffer。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratt的《Rubber Tree》。